Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu raum zeit dem podcast über raumfahrt und andere kosmische angelegenheiten mein name ist Tim Pritlove.
Begrüße alle zur ausgabe nummer siebenundachtzig unserer kleinen gesprächs- reihe,
über all die dinge die uns so über dem kopf hängen und,
wo wir dann immer den hals recken um sie sehen zu können wenn man überhaupt was ankommt und genau darüber gibt es nämlich heute,
wie man denn eigentlich so den blick nach oben sonst noch organisieren kann mal jenseits von der voll durch professionalisierten raumfahrt welt die wir ja sonst so oft.
Im fokus haben.
Und wollen ein bisschen sprechen über die amateure die leute und die szenen die das ganze mit herzblut und persönlichem interesse betreiben und wie das alles so organisiert ist und dazu begrüße ich meine,
gesprächspartnerin nämlich die carolin die carolin liefke hallo.
Hallo.
Carolin wir sind jetzt in heidelberg.
Da arbeitest du nämlich im haus der astronomie das richtig ne schön oben auf dem berg da wo man guten überblick über alles hat.
Bevor wir vielleicht darauf mal kommen würde mich mal interessieren was du eigentlich dein weg in die sterne gewesen ist wie wie bist du denn zu dem thema gekommen.
Schuld ist mein damaliger mathematiklehrer gewesen da war ich ja stolze dreizehn jahre alt.
Ich fand nämlich plötzlich dessen namen in der zeitung als es darum ging neunzehnhundertvierundneunzig viel ein komet oder besser gesagt mehrere kometen bruchstücke,
der hieß schuhmaker levi neun auf den jupiter das erregte einiges an aufsehen,
ja war dementsprechend auch spektakulär halt eben mit bildern in der zeitung und ja als kommentar lass ich da dann plötzlich den namen meines mathelehrer der sich als leiter der örtlichen sternwarte entpuppte und
da muss ich dann doch mal nachfragen was da so dahinter steckte.
Wo war das in lübeck aha okay das heißt das wusstest du sozusagen noch gar nicht ein bisschen zu geraten hat gesagt was was erlaube.
So so in der art genau das endete dann damit dass ich halt eben in der gastro meiner schule landete schließlich und endlich physik studiert und mich auf die astronomie spezialisierte und jetzt heute hier bin.
Okay verstehe ja schuhmaker levi neun oder vielleicht nochmal kurz sagen war so ein comedian wie du schon gesagt hast in den jupiter eingeschlagen ist und das besondere war daran dass man das ganz gut beobachten konnte oder.
Ja das war so etwas also ich hing dann halt zu hause so mit so dem.
Kleinen piraten fernrohr dass mein vater hatte um das als als zielfernrohr auf dem luftgewehr zu verwenden und visiertest dann den jupiter an hat natürlich damit nichts gesehen aber schon halt eben an an
stern warten halt eben hat man das durchaus erkennen können also als kleine dunkle pünktchen die halt da auf dem jupiter zu sehen gewesen sind.
Und dann machst du also vollkommen entflammt.
Das ging vergleichsweise schnell und vergleichsweise heftig genau.
Okay aber das zeigt ja dann auch schon wieder schnell das so wenn so ein spezielles engagement bei irgendwelchen leuten da ist dass das dann eben auch,
besondere wirkung entfalten kann was haben sie denn da vor ort getan in dieser das ist gesagt sternwarte lübeck.
Also ich bin damals dann halt eben noch gar nicht direkt mit der sternwarte in kontakt gekommen das kam dann später um
aber ich hatte dann halt auch relativ bald mein erstes eigenes größeres teleskop also über das piraten fernrohr hinaus weil man dann halt eben auch festgestellt hat ja man man kann da auch was selber machen kann da selber was sehen.
Und ich denke mal das ist halt auch gerade bei kindern und jugendlichen halt etwas wo man man sagen würde.
Also dieser dieser eine blick was weiß ich auf einen mondkrater auf den saturn mit seinen ring oder sowas das kann es sein was die leute ja festhängt festhängen lässt.
Für für immer mehr oder weniger also manchmal auch mit pausen das hat man viel das halt,
leute sich als kind als jugendliche für astronomie interessieren und dann aber erst später sagen hey das ist was das wollte ich schon immer mal machen als hobby.
Jetzt bist du wie ich schon gesagt habe beim haus der astronomie gelandet kannst du uns mal erzählen was das eigentlich für einen standort ist was du da machst.
Wir schimpfen uns zentrum für astronomische bildungs- und öffentlichkeitsarbeit wobei wir in dem sinne kein publikums trieb sind mit einer art oder museum oder sowas wo man,
mit öffnungszeiten hinkommen kann und mal gucken kann oder halt eben jeden abend ist eine show gibt im planetarium sondern ja wir versuchen eher hinter den kulissen dinge zu erarbeiten,
lehrerinnen und lehrern materialien für die schule zur verfügung zu stellen und so weiter und man kann natürlich aber trotzdem auch zu uns kommen.
Wir verfolgen alle möglichen projekte die irgendwie damit zu tun haben astronomie und astrophysik eben für jedermann verständlich zu machen.
Wie macht er das konkret also wie was was was wird da organisiert.
Das fängt ganz einfach an also im prinzip alle altersstufen so ab dem ab dem kindergarten werden bei uns in irgendeiner form versorgt also,
kindergartengruppen können zu uns kommen wir haben materialien die wir in die kindergärten geben können wir bilden erzieherinnen und erzieher aus das gleiche dann halt eben auch im grundschulbereich also
in zusammenarbeit hier halt eben mit der pädagogischen hochschule oder der universität dass wir halt wirklich die angehenden lehrerinnen und lehrer ausbilden dass halt eben,
in die schulen kommen kann.
Alles mögliche halt eben aber auch was ich sage mal einfach auto normal bürgerinnen ottonormalbürger interessiert halt eben wirklich einfach.
So zu machen dass es halt ja nicht einfach der wissenschaftler im elfenbeinturm irgendwelche unverständlichen,
an den kopf wirft sondern dass man dinge zum beispiel visualisiert also dass man wissenschaftliche daten.
Bildlich greifbar hat zum beispiel für die planetariums kuppel dass man kleine clips macht alles mögliche,
das mache ich natürlich ich nur nicht alleine sondern auch mit vielen kollegen und kolleginnen zusammen.
Ich würde mir gerne mal das beispiel des der physik lehrerinnen und lehrer herausnehmen ist das dann sozusagen.
Standard dass man dann irgendwann bei euch vorbeikommt oder findet das in manchen ausbildungsbereiche statt oder ist es eine private initiative die sozusagen von den leuten selber kommen muss mit euch das will ich mir ganz gerne auch mal ran geben da fahre ich mal hin.
Letztendlich ist natürlich alles was mit schule zu tun hat erstmal sowieso von bundesland zu bundesland unterschiedlich hier in baden-württemberg ist es halt so dass astronomie
bis zu einem gewissen punkt halt eben teil dessen ist was in physik in der schule gemacht wird was zum teil halt eben aber eben auch ja als als wahlpflichtfach kurs angeboten werden kann und dementsprechend
müssen auch angehende lehrerinnen und lehrer dafür ausgebildet werden also an der universität heidelberg zum beispiel ist es halt vorgeschrieben dass
angehende physiklehrer bei uns einen kurs belegen den wir einmal im jahr dann halt eben durchführen um den zu zeigen was gibt es inhaltlich in der gastronomie und dann halt eben auch,
wie kann man das schülerinnen und schüler verschiedene altersstufen halt eben auch vermitteln.
Aber ihr seid jetzt nicht teil der universität oder doch.
Das ist kompliziert also die die universität ist ein partner halt eben in dieser ganzen institution haus der astronomie,
noch die plank gesellschaft mit dem max-planck-institut für astronomie halt eben hauptvorteile da sind wir ja auch auf dem gelände mit drauf da ist aber auch die stadt heidelberg beteiligt da ist das land baden-württemberg als solches beteiligt und halt eben auch unser geldgeber
einer der vielen geldgeber mittlerweile die klaus tierer stiftung aber eben unser haupt.
Ja sollte man sich auf jeden fall mal anschauen vor allem auch von oben ich habe mir das ganze mal erflog es ist immer so meine art ist und schnell festgestellt das haus hatte eine schöne der milchstraße nach,
gebildete form wenn ich das richtig sehe oder.
Ja das ist auch absicht also wenn man sich das zum beispiel irgendwie auf google maps anguckt dann kann man das ziemlich gut sehen dass das gebäude also wirklich eine spiralgalaxien ähneln soll also
eines der vielen himmels objekte die es gibt aber halt eben auch dementsprechend markant wenn man also direkt davor steht dann sieht man das gar nicht so sehr aber von oben,
ist das tatsächlich einigermaßen schön zu sehen wenn wir dann jemals schon mal eine galaxie gesehen hat muss man da natürlich.
Spätestens wenn man rauskommt weiß man glaube ich.
Ja wir wollen ja ein bisschen so mal über die amateur seite sprechen das ist so ein begriff.
Mit dem ich immer so ein bisschen also ich persönlich hadere damit überhaupt nicht aber andere leute tun das war ja.
Amateur impliziert immer so ein bisschen so dieses so ja hat ja nichts drauf und ist ja nicht richtig ausgebildet und so weiter du bist ja nur ein amateur so nicht dieser formulierung ganz allgemein gesehen jetzt ganz unabhängig von von der astronomie.
Andererseits ist ja der wortsinn lieb die leute die es lieben sozusagen.
Es ist vor allen dingen tatsächlich so dass
in der gastronomie der begriff nicht so verstanden wird und zwar weder von profi-gastronomen die halt also wirklich dafür bezahlt werden dass sie betreiben noch von von den amateuren als solches selber sondern es halt schlicht und ergreifend eine kategorisierung aber ich würde sagen
der überwiegende teil der der profi-gastronomen zum beispiel wertschätzt das was was hobby-astrolog was amateur tun und in dem sinne
ich würde nicht sagen dass das irgendwie negativ belegt ist als begriff astronom ist ist ein festes wort und das ist das ist positiv besetzt.
Das ist gut dass es dass es so ist so es ist nicht unbedingt überall so aber quasi der bereich beginnt dort wo leute wo kann man denn dann so die trennung ziehen also sozusagen leute die nicht explizit dafür bezahlt werden.
Letztendlich wäre es genau das also diejenigen leute die eigentlich einen anderen beruf haben um ihren lebensunterhalt zu bestreiten sozusagen.
Jetzt gibt es ja eine relativ große amateur astronomenszene die man vielleicht so auf den ersten blick gar nicht so wahrnimmt.
Was würdest du denn mein wie groß dieser bereich ist.
Das ist ziemlich schwer abzuschätzen weil ja da gibt's auch nicht so richtig eine übersicht ich würde schon sagen das sind mehrere zehntausend leute in deutschland,
die man aber nie alle auf einen haufen bekommt also es gibt
leute die sind in vereinen organisiert es gibt leute die sind zum beispiel foren oder über soziale medien organisiert es gibt andere leute die machen das wirklich als einzelgänger oder schreibtischtäter und niemand weiß dass es sie gibt.
Ähm aber es sind natürlich bei weitem nicht so viele wie jetzt ich sage mal im östlichen fußballverein oder sowas aber trotzdem auch eine ansehnliche zahl.
Und wo findet man die also was sind denn so die orte die sich tummeln.
Zum einen tummeln sie sich halt eben ja an an den orten natürlich wo man das vermuten würde sprich an sternen warten,
da gibt es deutschlandweit natürlich auch mehrere hundert irgendwo also niedrig mehrere hundert,
vereine die jetzt vielleicht auch gar keine eigene sternwarte haben oder dabei sind halt eben eine aufzubauen.
Oder halt eben tatsächlich auch durchaus virtuell und sonst bei sich zu hause im eigenen garten.
So sagen die leute die einfach mit dem eigenen teleskop privat dinge tun ja was sind denn so die orte im netz wo sich das alles kondensiert.
Eine große tradition haben eigentlich die großen internetforen schon jetzt seit so knapp zwanzig jahren hat sich das herausgebildet dass es mehrere große internetforen gibt astronomie de astro treff
also zwei zwei große communitys die sich zum teil halt eben auch überschneiden wo sich die leute einfach auch
austauschen können also wirklich ganz klassische webfest wo die leute fragen stellen können ihre bilder präsentieren oder halt einfach auch.
Tatsächlich dazu aufrufen zu sagen ja wir treffen uns hier nächsten dienstag in der kneipe.
Sind die alle miteinander vergleichbar oder gibt's da unterschiedliche ausprägungen spezialisierung.
Also die großen foren sind da ziemlich allgemein gehalten die unterschiede liegen in erster linie so ein bisschen auch im in der art wie wieder miteinander umgegangen sind und halt eben auch einfach in den vorlieben der leute mit wem man sowieso schon sozusagen da länger rumhängt.
Ja klar der typische netzwerkeffekt aber gibt's dann spezialisierung auch also.
Das gibt es auch also es gibt dann halt eben kleinere foren die sich mit bestimmten unterthemen beschäftigen also gerade wenn es halt eben um speziellere gebiete,
da sind dann teilweise aber auch sowas wie mailingliste und sowas verbreitet wo man das gar nicht öffentlich mitbekommt was da passiert so in foren kann ja letztendlich jeder nachlesen was da passiert,
auch wenn man da vorher nicht mitglied gewesen ist aber es gibt natürlich auch viele geschlossene bereiche wo man halt ja ersten einblick hat wenn man auch wirklich selber drinnen steckt.
Geschlossen im sinne von dass er nicht jeder rein gelassen wird oder geschlossen in dem sinne dass es einem erstmal nicht klar ist war.
Ganz genau also man man muss erstmal wissen dass es existiert also dass beispielsweise so etwas wie eine mailingliste für astrofotografie existiert oder dergleichen und wenn man das nicht weiß dann kann man natürlich auch gar nicht sagen hey ich möchte dir gerne mal reingucken oder mitmachen nein nein nein.
Die schotten sich nicht ab sondern sind sozusagen nur nicht so sichtbar das wollte ich klarstellen ja was noch ein paar andere beispiele wo man vielleicht mal reinschauen möchte wenn man spezielle interessen hat.
Ja also letztendlich ist es natürlich so dass zum beispiel halt eben auch in den sozialen medien einiges ist da gibt's ein paar große facebook-gruppen,
sowohl deutschsprachige als dann halt auch wieder international,
wo wo die leute sich tummeln da ist einiges halt eben auch der große überregionale verein in deutschland ist die vereinigung der sternenfreund,
als klassischer verein eben organisiert in dem sinne in dem sich halt eben auch mittlerweile so an die viertausend leute aus ganz deutschland aber halt eben auch aus den nachbarländern zusammengeschlossen haben.
Was macht man da.
Es geht zum einen halt auch wirklich einfach um um die gemeinschaft um das gemeinsame interesse an der astronomie es gibt halt aber auch eine ganze reihe von fachgruppen an die zwanzig stück die sich dann halt wiederum speziellen themen widmen.
Ein wichtiger aspekt dabei ist halt aber eben zum beispiel auch.
Innerhalb der vvs wiederum dann die organisation also sprich die die sternwarte und vereine die als solches auch wieder mitglied werden können dann halt eben noch zu unterstützen.
Das heißt das ist ein ganz guter tipp sich so dort zu engagieren.
Letztendlich wenn jemand sagt ich interessiere mich für astronomie und ich möchte mal gucken wie das so geht,
der allererste tipp wäre denke ich mal wirklich sich erstmal um zu schauen wer ist lokal bei mir in der gegend wo gibt's da eine volks warte wo gibt's da einen verein wo gibt's vielleicht auch einfach nur ein stammtisch wo ich mal vorbeischauen kann,
wo ich dann halt vielleicht zum beispiel einfach auch mal selber durch einen teleskop gucken kann bevor ich selber mir eins kaufe oder sowas.
Guter punkt wenn man sich jetzt generell für astronomie interessiert,
vielleicht beobachten wir das erstmal so von der perspektive eines eines newcomers so man,
interessiert sich sozusagen dafür und möchte überhaupt selber erstmal die einen eigenen möglichkeiten herausfinden was würdest du denn so für den einstieg wählen oder was würdest du denn leuten raten die sich mehr mit dem sternen beobachtung
beschäftigen möchte.
Ja das kommt auch immer so ein bisschen drauf an wie die leute selber drauf sind also gerade wenn man den leuten online begegnet ist es tatsächlich so dass sie so eine gewisse scheu haben
lokal jetzt eben bei anderen amateur vorstellig zu werden und sagen hey,
interessiere mich könnt ihr mir nicht mal was zeigen und ja da ist es dann häufig einfacher den leuten erstmal so ein bisschen digital auf die sprünge zu helfen dass die eine idee bekommen können was es so alles,
worauf man sich spezialisieren kann viele leute heutzutage stolpern im internet über irgendwelche bilder und sagen hey so was möchte ich gerne selber machen,
stellen dann halt aber ziemlich schnell fest dass es gar nicht so einfach ist und suchen dann hilfe,
andere leute sagen ich möchte wirklich einfach nur mal gucken mich fasziniert das alles da oben,
aber wollen da teilweise dann eben auch so ein bisschen unter sich bleiben also wollen das als naturerlebnis was man halt dann häufig tatsächlich auch alleine macht,
einfach haben also was auch so ein bisschen einsamkeit naturverbundenheit hat ja den leuten kann man im wesentlichen dann eigentlich nur sagen ja macht einfach und guckt und wenn ihr mehr wissen wollt dann könnt ihr hier reinschauen und das ist die wissenschaft dahinter oder sowas.
Jetzt gibt's aber natürlich einige leute die das schon seit längerem betreiben und man fragt sich natürlich immer so richtig womit beschäftigen die sich denn jetzt eigentlich wirklich was wird denn von diesem amateurbereich,
abgedeckt was jetzt von der profi raumfahrt szene und astronomie szene vor allem natürlich nicht berührt wird.
Tatsächlich ist es letztendlich die masse die es macht also.
Viel viel mehr amateure als profi-gastronomen und wenn man wenn man sich anschaut was was die leute tun können,
dann ist es häufig so dass profi-gastronomen beispielsweise auch hilfe suchen bei einfach dinge für die sie selber nicht genug kapazitäten haben und wo man sich dann zum beispiel auch als amateur astronom einfach einbringen kann man profi-gastronomen unterstützt.
Da gibt es eine ganze reihe von leuten die sich engagieren in verschiedenen spezialgebiete dann auf man sich teilweise auch dann selber erstmal in die wissenschaft einarbeiten muss um zu verstehen ja was mache ich denn da eigentlich oder was kann ich denn da tun
und auch eine ganze reihe von leuten tatsächlich die das auch sehr sehr gut machen also obwohl sie selber nie,
physik studiert haben und alles was damit verbunden ist trotzdem dann halt wirklich auch experten auf gewissen gebieten sind zum beispiel spektrum kopie auswertung von von stern spektren und sich dann halt mit mit,
ganz ganz speziellen himmels objekten befassen mit von denen meine oma an ihrem leben noch nie gehört hat zum beispiel.
Man würde ja erwarten und das gibt es sicherlich auch das das so eine gewisse soll ich sagen.
Vorbehalte gibt ne wenn man dann erstmal so voll ausgebildet durch studiert ist und sich dann in entsprechenden kreisen bewegt wo es allen anderen auch genauso geht dann ist es ja ein gewisser hinsicht auch eine.
Eine mühe sozusagen leute die nicht erstmal auf demselben wissensstand sind in solche projekte auch wieder mit einzubringen.
Hast du da erfahrung wie wie leichtes einzelnen feld das dann auch organisiert zu bekommen oder wie schwer und was wie man sozusagen dieses problem da etwas mehr motivieren kann.
Das ist tatsächlich denke ich mal ein ziemlich großes problem,
häufig erfordert das tatsächlich dass die leute sich erstmal selbstständig da so ein bisschen dann eben auch einarbeiten das denen dann
gesagt wird ja hier kannst du mal gucken oder hier kannst du mir mal über die schulter gucken aber danach musst du dann halt selber schauen wie es irgendwo geht ein patentrezept dafür gibt's glaube ich gar nicht dadurch dass die sachen teilweise so speziell sind.
Hauptsache ist denke ich irgendwo dass man spaß an der sache hat wenn man sagt also das das interessiert mich jetzt das reizt mich jetzt also ich möchte aus diesem foto mehr rausholen ich möchte irgendwie,
rauskriegen was ist da und damit auf sich hat ich möchte wissen warum dieser stern jetzt diese komischen helligkeits enderung macht wenn man sich an solchen sachen festbeißen kann und sagt das ist irgendwas was mich wirklich reizt dann hat man,
eigentlich sein thema gefunden und die technik die da dahinter steckt um das dann halt auch wirklich angehen zu können das ist dann halt was was man wo man sich dann halt durchbeißt.
Aber ist das nicht vor allem in der arbeit im mindset die man da leisten muss und was was sind so deine erfahrungen wie die leute das so handhaben.
Normalerweise entweder machen sie es einfach oder sie suchen sich dann doch irgendwo anderes gebiet irgendwo also das ist.
Ist das eine rolle die dir vielleicht manchmal zukommt dass sozusagen die profis bei dir andocken und sagen so hier guck mal wie könnte ich denn so eine so eine amateur für mich nutzbar machen.
Also das kriegen die normalerweise von ganz alleine hin normalerweise ist es das thema was fasziniert und die leute kommen dann.
Die die wirklich wollen kommen von alleine also man findet eigentlich immer genug die sagen das reizt mich jetzt da würde ich gerne mitmachen da würde ich gerne dabei sein wenn man wenn man so ein thema hat also das ist normalerweise gar nicht so das problem.
Das problem ist halt tatsächlich eher für für das individuum dann vielleicht dass ich dann vielleicht nicht traut sagt oh das das kann ich nicht da habe ich keine ahnung von oder sowas umgekehrt dann zu sagen dass das das traue ich mich jetzt einfach da das versuche ich einfach mal.
Was würdest du den leuten so raten wie man dann sozusagen da herangeht einfach mal 'ne mail schreibt.
Also häufig ist es tatsächlich so dass da natürlich schon bestehende kanäle irgendwo genutzt werden also wenn man jetzt weiß also die und die person hat schon mal bei so einem projekt mitgemacht.
Wir machen hier jetzt bilder die lange belichtet sind auf den himmel objekte sichtbar werden sollen die man vorher noch nie gesehen hat und hat damit so eine art neu entdeckung gemacht,
wenn da leute schon mal vorher mitgemacht haben bei sowas dann fragt man die halt ey habt ihr lust mal ein ähnliches projekt zu machen oder kennst du noch jemanden der da halt auch mitmachen würde und das ist so ein bisschen mundpropaganda häufig.
Heißt dann halt tatsächlich auch dass man so ein bisschen in der szene drin sein sollte um an sowas zu gelangen häufig auch,
gerade bei den spezielleren sachen ist es aber auch tatsächlich so,
wie in der wissenschaft ja auch da die zusammenarbeit halt das ist was zählt also während jemand der einfach nur sagt ich habe freude daran mit meinem teleskop im garten bei mir zu hause im blick an den himmel zu werfen der braucht.
Für dieses hobby ja eigentlich gar nicht so den direkten kontakt zu jemand anderem der das ähnlich macht klar kann man sich auch da gegenseitig austauschen dass man,
sagt hier hast du das himmels objekt schon mal gesehen und wie sahen das bei dir aus und hast du dieses und jenes detail erkennen können braucht es tatsächlich nicht.
Also diesen spezielleren wissenschaftlich angehauchten sachen ist es so dass halt eben ohne zusammenarbeit nichts geht.
Jetzt würde ich natürlich ganz gerne mal ein paar beispiele hören von erfolgreichen amateur astronomen und astronomen,
was was die sozusagen ganz konkret,
getan haben und vor allem womit also man denkt ja immer man braucht dann irgendwie so eine große kuppel auf dem dach die dann nachts bedrohlich aus fährt dass es kann ja wahrscheinlich nicht sein.
Nicht aber es ist tatsächlich so dass man schon ich sage mal nicht ganz kleine geldbeträge auch tatsächlich.
In seinen teleskop investieren kann das nimmt schnell mal höhere vierstellige oder noch höhere beträge eben auch an was die leute da so
in ihrer ausstattung investieren also,
teleskop computer steuerung kameras und so weiter plus auch wo wirklich irgendwelche software das kann schon auch eben ins geld gehen gerade wenn man da was qualitativ hochwertiges haben will trotzdem kann man halt viel mit,
ich sage mal vergleichsweise günstige material halt eben heutzutage auch erreichen dass es durchaus machbar.
Zum beispiel nennen was man sich so zulegen könnte man jetzt mal ganz unabhängig davon ob man gerade jetzt das geld,
hat oder nicht aber einfach auch mal so eine vorstellung davon zu bekommen so.
Ich bin jetzt nicht sagen geld spielt keine rolle aber wollen wir mal in so für manchen vielleicht erschwinglichen bereichen wo wonach würde man den eigentlich greifen was braucht man denn,
wann macht einen teleskop sinn um überhaupt ein nennenswerten
einblick zu erhalten und irgendwie auch so auf diesen film zu kommen immer ich kenne das mal so ein bisschen mit mit sport und wenn man irgendwie inlineskates kann man sich natürlich für für dreißig euro kaufen dann fährt man zehn meter stellt fest so ja
quietscht alles läuft alles gar nicht vielleicht nicht mein sport hätte man irgendwie vor hundert euro losgelegt merkt man gleich so wow geil das werde ich jetzt auch weiterhin betreiben steigt dann auch vom gerät her irgendwann mal in andere profi lassen auf also sozusagen so ein so ein mindesteinkommen ab
dem spaß macht.
Also das das prinzip kann man natürlich eins zu eins übertragen also es gibt halt eben auch ich sage mal die billig teleskope die man vor weihnachten beim discounter kriegen kann und mit denen man normalerweise herzlich wenig spaß hat weil alles wackelt und aus plastik ist und dann irgendwie abbricht oder sowas.
Das problem ist umgekehrt es gibt so viele verschiedene teleskop typen und dadrunter ist keine eierlegende wollmilchsau dabei.
Okay das wollte darauf wollte ich auch nicht hinaus und nun mal ein beispiel nennen.
Was weiß ich also sagen wir jemand hat fünfhundert euro übrig und er möchte einfach nur schauen dann sagen wir soll ein teleskop für den handbetrieben sein und sogenanntes teleskop möglichst großer durchmesser,
sowas wie zwanzig zentimeter aufwärts als sogenanntes newton teleskop dann halt eben eingehängt in eine in eine holzkonstruktion kann man als fertiggericht kaufen.
Was heißt dobs teleskop an der stelle.
Wurde entwickelt vor einiger zeit von einem amerikanischen hobby-astrolog namens john dobs leider verstorben mittlerweile,
halt einfach nach dem prinzip ein möglichst großes teleskop möglichst großer durchmesser möglichst stabil aufgestellt aber trotzdem möglichst billig.
Was heißt möglichst groß also wie groß muss man sich das ding so vorstellen drei meter zwanzig zentimeter.
Ist nicht mehr händelbar aber es gibt hobby-astrolog die haben teleskope mit ein meter durchmesser zum beispiel das wird dann aber schon so lange dass man dann mit einer leiter drauf rumklettern muss.
Was was macht dieses teleskop jetzt konkret aus also man man sagen sie nicht alle gleich.
In dem falle wenn man die sich zum beispiel mit zwanzig zentimeter durchmesser kauft dann sind die tatsächlich alle gleich kommen auch von der stange sozusagen aus fernost geliefert.
Alle teleskope sind gleich oder alle teleskop.
Das prinzip in dem sinne ist gleich also sprich wie das wie das aufgebaut ist ich habe das rohr und hänge das ein in eine holz halterung und das ist das prinzip dahinter.
Man muss das dann per hand bedienen und es gibt wiederum andere teleskope natürlich aber auch die dann computergesteuert sind und da ist es dann halt eben so da investiere ich jetzt nicht in die optik dass ich also möglichst viel sehen kann sondern da investiere ich mir am die technik um zum beispiel scharfe fotos zu kriegen.
Was könnte man mit diesem job sein teleskop so für fünfhundert euro was könnte man damit sehen.
Also ich könnte eine lange liste von himmels objekten aufblättern wo mehrere tausend himmels objekte dann damit zu sehen sind je nach,
ob man jetzt halt eben in der großstadt sitzt oder halt eben unter einem dunklen land himmel,
und je größer ich das gleiche teleskop dann halt aber wähle ich kann dasselbe prinzip natürlich nicht nur mit zwanzig sondern auch mit dreißig zentimeter durchmesser wählen dann sehe ich halt mehr einfach weil das teleskop mehr licht sammeln kann.
Okay der ist schon klar aber wenn ich jetzt mal bei diesem beispiel bleibe so fünfhundert euro ausgegeben dann hat das ding was für ein durchmesser so zehn zentimeter,
zwanzig zentimeter okay so jetzt fahr ich irgendwie raus aus der stadt ein bisschen auf den acker nicht unbedingt jetzt in so einem sternen park aber die lichter der stadt sind schon bisschen man sieht so so in der ferne das glühen des ortes.
Was sehe ich vom mond was sehe ich vom vom jupiter.
Vom mond würde man genau das gleiche sehen wie wenn man in der stadt heraus auch beobachten würdet also in dem falle bräuchte ich da jetzt nicht rausfahren.
Man sieht hier noch größer sieht man krater.
Man sieht ihn größer man sieht krater männer die eher nicht.
Also wenn ich den käse sehe ja dann ist vielleicht mal der besuch beim augenarzt fällig.
Also das dieses streben nach mehr durchmesser da geht es dann tatsächlich weniger um die himmels objekte die ich sowieso schon mit bloßem auge sehen kann sondern halt eben um die die mit dem bloßen auge nicht mehr zu sehen sind.
Größeres teleskop braucht auch der ist mit bloßem auge zu sehen.
Ja gut aber nicht in seinem in seiner ring struktur also man man sieht ihn irgendwie leuchten also ich habe vor einem jahr das erste mal tatsächlich erstmal so ein größeres teleskop ich könnte jetzt
benennen was es konkret war,
so den saturn gesehen und es war dann sozusagen genauso dieser erste effekt und wahrscheinlich sehr gut sehr viel besser kennst als ich so dass man sich denn so so,
sieht ja wirklich so aus wie er immer so auf den fotos abgetötet wird
ist ja alles gar nicht fake und ich fand diesen diesen effekt eigentlich ganz ich war jetzt nicht im eigentlichen sinne überrascht aber ich war überrascht davon dass das bei mir,
so eine verbindung auf einmal hergestellt hat mit der ich eigentlich gar nicht so gerechnet hab also auf der einen seite war das so so ja so.
So hab ich's mir immer vorgestellt habe ich bisher immer gesehen aber es ist mal selber auch gesehen zu haben schafft irgendwie nochmal eine ganz andere.
Ganz andere verbindung eine ganz andere mentale verbindung zu zu der ganzen sache macht wahrsten sinne des wortes greifbarer.
Gerade bei den planeten hat man häufig noch so den effekt die leute erwarten eigentlich dass einen das format füllend anspringt oder sowas also so wie sie das halt von bildern im internet kennen und das ist dann natürlich auch wieder nicht sondern auch so ein planet ist winzig winzig klein,
wenn man mit dem teleskop also gewaltige vergrößerung da gerade bewerkstelligt und es bleibt trotzdem halt eigentlich vergleichsweise klein man kann immer noch gut details erkennen man kann die ringe sehen.
Man kriegt dann so ein gefühl dafür wie weit ist das eigentlich weg ich gucke das jetzt schon so groß an ich gucke mit gewaltiger vergrößerung dahin und trotzdem kann ich gerade mal erkennen dass das diese ring planet ist und dass er jetzt mir nicht format füllt anspringt und das,
geht dann tatsächlich ja nur mit einer raumsonde die da hinfliegt das wiederum liegt außerhalb der möglichkeiten von oder normalen mensch also viele viele leute die da sind gucken sagen jetzt jetzt realisiere ich erst wie groß das universum ist.
Schauen wir mal mit dem und mit dem kleinen zwanzig zentimeter teleskop weiter durch die gegend okay saturn kann man irgendwie erkennen wo hört's auf mit dem erkennen was kann man damit noch gut sehen.
Ich kann dann eben zum beispiel solche galaxien nachdem das haus der astronomie nachempfunden ist erkennen.
Also zum beispiel die andere mehr da galaxie dir.
Genau wobei ich auch eben für die wiederum zum beispiel gar nichts und brauchen da reicht der gute sternenhimmel oder aber ein fernglas tatsächlich ist das so die leute denken ja immer vergrößerung ist das ein und alles beim teleskop,
das ist es gar nicht mal die guten beobachtungs und auch sowas wie wie viel licht kann das teleskop dann überhaupt sammeln entscheiden darüber ob ich überhaupt irgendwas erkennen kann.
Zugegebenermaßen halt eben auch so ein bisschen die erfahrung das geübte auge sieht mehr als jemand der einfach nur mal kurz für eine sekunde durchguckt und so schnell auf die schnelle nix erkannt hat.
Ja was sind denn das geübte auge dann.
Ganz ehrlich bei den allermeisten himmels objekten die man da oben am himmel hat so ein paar graue wölkchen und matsch.
Also man darf nicht erwarten dass einem da die bunten bilder die man aus dem internet kennt halt eben genauso farbig im teleskop anspringen nachts und alle katzen grau und nachts sind auch die allermeisten himmels objekte grau also wenn ich einfach nur durchschaue kann unser auge
bei den allerwenigsten himmels objekten farbe erkennen das klappt bei sternen das klappt bei dem planeten,
so andeutung weise bei einigen sogenannten nebeln also leuchtenden gaswolke aber auch da im vergleich mit einem foto sieht das völlig anders aus,
und es ist tatsächlich dann auch eher so ein bisschen für die leute die wirklich beobachten also durch das teleskop schauen und dinge sehen wollen die dann vielleicht zum beispiel auch in skizzen,
dokumentieren wollen halt eher so die herausforderung was kann ich in diesem schwarz-weiß was ich da erkenne in diesem hell dunkel was kann ich an details ausmachen die dann tatsächlich auch echt sind und die ich mir nicht nur einbilde.
Dass man diese farben nicht wahrnimmt hat einfach was damit zu tun dass man sehr viel mehr licht über die zeit sammeln müsste damit
die auch deutlich herauskommen also unser kurzer direkter augenblick im wahrsten sinne des wortes der der erhält einfach nicht genug licht um diese farbe impressionen zu erhalten.
Ganz genau also.
Die fotos die man die man hat von den himmels objekten da kann man sich drüber streiten ob die jetzt farbe sind aber normalerweise zumindest die die gruppen farbtöne die man hat wenn man da jetzt halt mit einer normalen,
kamera draufgehalten hat die sind in dem sinne jetzt nicht nicht völlig falsch oder sowas es sei denn der astrofotografie das in der bildbearbeitung absichtlich so gesetzt,
das menschliche auge würde sie nicht sehen weil unsere farbwahl sich schlicht und ergreifend einfach ausschaltet wenn nicht mehr genug licht da ist.
Das heißt wenn man jetzt die begeisterung aufrecht erhalten will die jetzt vielleicht von diesem kleinen dobs teleskop schon mal ausgelöst wurde wie gesagt weil so immerhin,
planet und so im im detail also ich finde ich irgendwie bemerkenswert das ist irgendwie so dachte ich mir so okay alles klar dass das das verbindet mich jetzt so ein bisschen mit dem universum
aber es ist richtig verstanden habe der eigentliche kick liegt sozusagen jetzt da drin auch noch.
Richtige bilder zu erzeugen die das rausholen was man eben rausholen kann auch mit einer,
benachteiligten beobachtungsposten die man ja eigentlich in den meisten orten hat,
so diese fünfhundert euro ding was wir jetzt eben benannt haben das hat ja sozusagen nichts anderes als die beobachtungsobjekt das heißt da ist jetzt keine kamera mit drin.
In welche preisregulierung stoße ich jetzt vor wenn ich dasselbe in mit digitalkamera oder mit der möglichkeit bilder aufzunehmen und licht über längere zeit zu sammeln was muss ich jetzt investieren.
Ja also wir können vielleicht mal eine eins davor schreiben und dann hat man schon mal ein gutes einsteiger um auch eben fotos zu machen wobei man auch da wieder unterscheiden muss,
wenn man jetzt zum beispiel sagt ich bin zufrieden damit dass ich einfach meine handy-kamera als cola halte und mal die mondkrater oder die planeten die ich so wie ich sie um cola sehe halt einfach als vielleicht dann auch nicht hundertprozentig scharfes
foto dann aber hinterher in der in der handy galerie habe und sage hey das ist mein bild dass ich selber aufgenommen habe dann reicht halt eben schon sowas,
aber tatsächlich da jetzt dann auch gehobene ansprüche hat dann ja liegt man sich irgendwann,
die immer mehr und mehr gehobene ausstattung dann auch für die gehobene ansprüche dann natürlich auch,
halt zusammen das kann sowas sein wie eine spiegelreflexkamera zu kaufen die ich dann ans teleskop anschließe statt des coladas dass man also gar nicht mehr durchschaut,
das kann aber auch eine speziellere astro kamera sein die dann durchaus auch mal gerne mehrere tausend euro kostet die dann halt eben auch eine eigene stromversorgung braucht die gekühlt wird und so weiter.
Die ich mit einem laptop steuere vielleicht.
Also da das läppert sich dann natürlich auch was man da dann noch alles an zubehör braucht lauter anschluss teile adapter farbfilm womöglich wenn's eine schwarz-weiß klammern wird.
Das heißt das eigentliche kamerateam weil ist selten teil des teleskop.
Das ist ein extra gerät das ist,
grundsätzlich fällt was was eigentlich sehr sehr schön ist teleskope sind unglaublich modular also ich kann das rohr mit einem anderen unterbau kombinieren ich kann kaufen von der einen firma und mit einem teleskop von der anderen firma miteinander verheiraten die anschlüsse sind alle passend,
identisch.
Generell üblicherweise üblicherweise.
Üblicherweise ja also es gibt ein paar ausnahmen natürlich und man findet von allem auf alles irgendwelche adapter teile üblicherweise.
Kostet dann natürlich auch noch mal wieder ein bisschen extra aber geht und es auch genauso gedacht dass man die verschiedenen hersteller miteinander kombinieren kann,
ganz wichtiger punkt ist der unterbau des teleskop das nennt man die sogenannte montiert also sprich einmal das was das teleskop,
an jedem beliebigen stelle des himmels fahren lässt wenn ich das nicht per hand einfach irgendwie so ausrichte was mir gleichzeitig die erddrehung ausgleich wenn wir die himmels objekte.
Nicht nur die sonne sondern alles da oben am himmel im osten aufgehen und im westen wieder runtergehen das heißt das bewegt sich das steht nicht still für uns scheinbar und welchen teleskop einmal ausrichte.
Das soll die ganze zeit ausgerichtet bleiben auf das himmels objekt dann muss das teleskop hinterher bewegt werden und sagt dann nachführen,
da brauche ich also irgendeine art von motorisierung die computergesteuert sein kann und weil die für fotos dann auch sehr sehr präzise sein muss muss dann da noch wieder einiges an technik hinterher dass mir also diese präzision gewährleistet ist dann hinterher auf meinen bildern die sterne nicht irgendwelche eier werden.
Das heißt diese für diese nach führung muss ja sozusagen das system auch wissen wo ist man und welche zeit ist et cetera.
Kann man in vereinfachter form rein mechanisch lösen das muss halt so ausgerichtet werden dass die nachfolge bewegung genau passt für den jeweiligen standort auf der erde das kann man durch einstellen der drehachsen erreichen,
bis zu einem gewissen punkt dann halt eben wenn man sagt ich will da jetzt auf den super genau hinterher auf meinem bild sehen dass das auch wirklich scharf ist obwohl das eine stunde lang belichtet wurde,
dann muss ich's halt immer präziser und immer präziser machen und während der belichtung irgendwelche korrekturen anbringen am besten automatisch das nennt man sogenanntes guiding.
Eine zweite kamera hat,
da dann vielleicht auch noch guckt und wo man sozusagen einen stern eingeloggt hat und wenn der sich einen pixel weiterbewegt dann wird die andere kamera halt gegen bewegt.
Ah das war so eine art tracking macht prinzip hat man ja irgendwie auch in der trick technik ähnliche geschichten also so eine referenz hatten danach bewegt sich dann irgendwie alles.
Sowas in der art ganz genau.
Ok wenn das so ein modular ist vielleicht,
ist es auch wert mal so ein blick auf diese einzelnen module zu werfen um mal so eine vorstellung davon zu bekommen was was eigentlich die einzelnen wichtigen komponenten sind beim teleskop und wo man da vielleicht einzelnen drauf
achten sollte oder welche spielereien ist da gibt's natürlich erstmal an mit dem kern teleskop ding nämlich an.
Erstmal gibt's dann natürlich ja man man würde sagen tubus also lateinisch rohr,
man hat da dann halt eben die optik drin das kann ein linsen teleskop sein dann hat man eine linse linsen teleskope sind üblicherweise halt eben lang also auch klassisch halt eben ja wie man sich ein teleskop vorstellt eben als langes rohr wo man hinten durchguckt.
Auch da wiederum gibt es verschiedene ausführungen wo man verschiedene qualitäten hat von der linse die dann meistens aus verschiedenen glasuren noch zusammengesetzt ist,
dann gibt es eine ganze reihe von verschiedenen typen von spiegelteils gruppen am weitesten verbreitet sind da newton teleskope das sind teleskop oder hat man hinten ein,
spiegel,
der das licht dann natürlich halt nicht nur sammelt sowie die linse sondern gleichzeitig halt eben auch noch zurück reflektiert und um zu verhindern dass das einfach wieder in die gleiche richtung rausgeht wie man halt geguckt hat braucht man noch einen zweiten spiegel der ist dann an der seite raus lenkt und da,
man hat entweder durch oder hat seine kamera dann hinten dran das sind alles kody lassen sich vergleichsweise günstig herstellen deshalb sind die relativ weit verbreitet.
Wiederum gibt's wo dann dieser zweite spiegel das nicht zur seite raus lenkt sondern nochmal wieder direkt zurück und damit man da dann halt aber was sehen kann muss der große spiegel den man zuerst hatte in der mitte ein loch haben und dann kann man dann wiederum hinten,
eine kamera anbauen oder das cola zum durchschauen haben.
Auch da gibt es dann noch wieder verschiedene unter ausführungen je nachdem welche form dieser spiegel hat also der darf ja nicht einfach,
eben sein so wie der badezimmerspiegel sondern der muss halt leicht gekrümmt sein damit er das licht auch wirklich bündeln kann soviel linse auch.
Je nachdem welche form der dann hat kann man da auch noch verschiedene formen miteinander kombinieren und dann hat man noch wieder verschiedene teleskop typen die dann halt auch wieder unterschiedliche eigenschaften haben zum beispiel,
einige sind besser geeignet für fotografie andere sind besser geeignet zum durchschauen noch wieder andere sind dann gut geeignet um da halt eben auch bestimmte messinstrumente anzuhängen wo man einfach nur an einem bestimmten punkt nicht messungen machen möchte oder so was.
Also es ist ganz ganz unterschiedlich dann tatsächlich auch wofür diese verschiedenen teleskop typen eingesetzt.
Okay aber das wird das der teleskop typ wird primär von diesem tourbus sozusagen definiert.
Definiert wird er hauptsächlich von der optik also linse oder spiegel und spiegel wenn ja welcher.
Okay also tubus mit der mit dem optik soll also ich habe das jetzt sozusagen als ein ein objekt gesehen weil das kauft man ja auch als eins.
Oder man baut es selber das gibt es tatsächlich auch also es gibt eine ganze reihe von amateur die sich ihre teleskope tatsächlich komplett selber bauen und das beinhaltet unter anderem auch das schleifen dieses spiegels also dass man sich einen großen glasglocke kauft,
und dann wird er in form gebracht und auch teilweise selber beschichtet oder bei einer firma zum geschichten gegeben und dann baue ich auch noch das teleskop drumherum also auch das gibt es.
Das überrascht mich jetzt okay.
Die szene ist sogar gar nicht so klein im gegenteil weil das natürlich eine möglichkeit ist mit vergleichsweise wenig finanziell im aufwand also glas block kaufen ist,
gerade bei einem großen teleskop deutlich günstiger als dann ein fertigen teleskop spiegel in der qualität wie ich ihn als jemand der das sowas schon mal gemacht hat er da ein bisschen übung drin hat halt eben selber herstellen kann,
so was würde dann schnell beträge kosten die man sich nicht mehr so einfach leisten kann den glas block dagegen schon.
Funktioniert dann auch gut.
Sagen wir's mal so übung macht auch da den meister da gibt's dann halt eben tatsächlich auch wieder genau leute die sich darüber austauschen wie kann ich sowas machen welche techniken kann ich da anwenden ja die das dann auch wirklich zur perfektion gebracht haben solche sachen.
Teilweise dann halt eben auch die selbstgebauten teleskope dann weiterverkaufen einfach um das nächste bauen zu können.
Teleskop bauen ich werde das spannend das ist aber noch ein bisschen bleiben also wir haben jetzt diesen tubus mit der
optik das definiert sozusagen wie das an sich funktioniert und je nachdem wie komplex und groß vor allem diese optik und das rohr damit natürlich auch ausfällt umso mehr chancen habe ich
licht überhaupt erstmal effizient einzusammeln.
Brauchen wir jetzt irgendwie noch so ein ziel fernrohr braucht man noch irgendwas ist ja so ein bisschen so ein problem ich habe das irgendwann auch mal probiert,
erst mal irgendwas zu finden wenn man so durch so einen kleinen kanal durchschaut der alles so sehr vergrößert und man hat dann auf einmal unheimlich viele
sterben und weiß nicht mehr wo oben und unten ist wie wie bewerkstelligt man das überhaupt.
Es gibt natürlich ich sage mal,
eine ganze reihe von leuten die tatsächlich am himmel einfach so weit auskennen dass sie sagen aber wenn ich jetzt den stern anvisiere und dann bisschen daneben peile dann finde ich da himmels objekt x,
leute die da so ein wandelndes himmels telefon telefonbuch sind sozusagen die gibt es,
aber sonst kann man sich natürlich auch mit sternen karten behelfen die einen sagen da und da ist was zu sehen oder man befragt halt eben entsprechendes computerprogramm das software die genau weiß wo sind welche himmels objekte zu sehen und.
Wenn ich das dann wiederum zum beispiel kombiniere mit mit was motorisierten als unterbau für das teleskop dann kann ich auch sowas machen wie teleskop dahin,
wenn ich das richtig aufgebaut habe und das alles richtig programmiert ist dann tut es das auch klappt in den seltensten fällen auf anhieb und man muss natürlich auch leider wiederum wissen was man tut aber das prinzip ist natürlich genau das also dass man sich da das digitale helferlein dann zu nutze machen.
Also man braucht keine zielfernrohr braucht vor allem eine ordentliche unterbau und im idealfall halt so ein motor der automatisch angesteuert werden kann von was auch immer.
Wie gesagt wenn man das nicht selber macht also ich beispielsweise bevorzuge die variante per hand und per sternkarte andere leute haben halt eben nicht den nerv und sagen ja brauche ich nicht,
lasse ich den computer übernehmen und investiere dann halt da dann eben auch das geld stabilität ist da übrigens auch eine ganz entscheidende sache also,
alles was man hat an unterbau auch an an drei beinen womöglich an stativ,
unterhalb des teleskop selber muss das ganze natürlich auch vernünftig tragen können und darf nix wackeln da darf nicht irgendwie ein leichter windhauch kommen und schon schwingt alles und ich sehe dann halt nur noch das bild hin und her schwanken wenn ich da durch gucke.
Das ist halt auch was wo viele,
sag mal komplett teleskope die man so kaufen kann irgendwo dran kranken das nämlich das teleskop an sich meistens gar nicht so schlecht ist aber alles was darunter ist eigentlich für ein teleskop nummer kleiner gedacht ist.
Das heißt man muss eigentlich auf alles achten.
Auch dementsprechend.
Wenn man wenn man sich überlegt was man für ein teleskop kauf ist es häufig auch besser einzelteile miteinander zu kombinieren und ich dann jeweils genau das passende teil,
auszusuchen was dann halt auch genau den zweck erfüllt den man haben möchte also,
dass man jetzt nicht sagt irgendwie ich kaufe das fertig teilt weil dann kauft man zweimal weil man dann nachrüsten muss nachbessern muss mit irgendeinem teil was sich als flaschenhals erwiesen hat für das was man gerne machen möchte also und sagt ich will hier
vernünftige fotos kriegen aber irgendwie die montiert ist nicht stark genug da muss ich halt eine neue nachkaufen die dann halt.
Teleskop vernünftig trägt und ja diese nachfüllbar sauber genug macht damit meine fotos auch so werden wie ich sie haben will.
Okay also korrekter unterbau sollte stabil sein sollte nicht wackeln sollte erdbebensicher sein sollte vor allem.
Noch nicht aber gucken wir mal.
Sollte auf jeden fall in dem wind standhalten ich meine man kann ja eine sternenklare nacht haben aber trotzdem hat irgendwie wind
beziehungsweise wenn man dann auch noch viele interessierte leute drumherum hat die alle irgendwo mal anfassen und so weiter dann wackelt halt auch sehr schnell,
stabil aufsetzen stabil verankert sein vor allem.
Man unterschätzt das natürlich vor allen dingen auch also wir vergrößern ja wir vergrößern um gewaltige zahlenwerte irgendwie sowas wie hundert oder zweihundert,
also wenn ich nur eine ganz winzige verschiebung habe an einem teleskop die sich einfach ergibt weil da jetzt irgendwie so ein leiser windhauch kommt oder weil ich da aus versehen mal anfassen die ich gar nicht sehe an dem eigentlichen fernrohr selber,
die vergrößerung wird die natürlich auch hundert oder zweihundert fach verstärkt und dann sehe ich die wackeln sofort.
Also das was wir auf den ersten blick vielleicht so als stabil empfinden würden ist dann vielleicht gar nicht so stabil wie wir das eigentlich eher denken und das macht sich dann erst bemerkbar welches dann halt wirklich auch,
sehe oder welchen hinterher merkt oh mein foto ist nix geworden.
Kommen wir zurück zu den komponenten also ich habe jetzt ein korrektes stativ das auch so richtig total verankert da kann man anfassen da kann's erkannt stürmen nichts wackelt das ding ist korrekt,
ausgerichtet liefert mir jetzt quasi einen ordentlichen lichtstrahl und übergibt mir den dann am cola richtig wo man dann,
einfach so einen aufsatz haben kann wo man halt einfach das auge drauf setzen kann oder eben auch eine kamera.
Das ist das wo ich das auge drauf setze und wenn ich die kamera dran tue dann kommt das cola normalerweise ab und die kamera stattdessen dran.
Okay genau da habe ich.
Das teleskop wird dann sozusagen ein gewaltiges teleobjektiv einfach für die kamera.
Ja ok und dann habe ich da auch so einen typischen kamera anschluss oder dass dann geht's mit dem adapter schon los.
Genau also da gibt's anschlüsse dass ich sage hier statt einem kamera objektiv schließe ich jetzt einfach die digitale spiegelreflexkamera da an.
Also so so ein nikon objektiv wo man so den normale anschrauben das gibt's dann sozusagen als adapter und dann schreibe ich einfach meine kamera da an und dann zack.
Ganz genau das und genau das gleiche dann halt eben auch bei spezial-kamera ras die halt wirklich nur in der gastronomie eingesetzt werden hat man dann die passenden anschlüsse das ist direkt da dran kommt und dann kann ich loslegen.
Aber das ist ja im prinzip schon mal auch ein ganz ganz coole ansatz für leute die sagen wir mal ohnehin schon,
kamera nerds sind die für für die vielleicht ist astronomie bisher noch gar nicht so das thema war aber die schon relativ viel investiert haben in entsprechende kameratechnik also entweder in richtige,
analoge spiegelreflexkameras oder heutzutage als digitale die dann wissen so ah okay alles klar ich kann mir jetzt noch einen teil kaufen und kann da.
Direkt mit meinem kamera körper ran und ab da alles verwenden was ich selber auch schon gut beherrsche und gut kann.
Zum beispiel wobei natürlich die schwierigkeiten in der gastronomie normalerweise immer noch was anderes ist wie wenn man jetzt nicht irgendwie auf.
Wilde tiere fotografieren irgendwie sowas spezialisiert hat man hat irgendwie.
Durch die art und weise wie in der gastronomie fotografiert wird also durch längere belichtungszeiten also belichtungszeiten die üblicherweise sowas sind wie mehrere minuten,
halt eben nicht nur ein bild zu fotografieren sondern gleich mehrere die dann miteinander kombiniert werden zu einem mehrere stundenlang insgesamt beleuchteten bild zum beispiel,
hat man eine ganz andere taktik dann natürlich auch von der bildaufnahme,
aber das ist das was da so an an lernkurve mit dazugehört wie mache ich eigentlich so ein astro-fotos was sind da so die heute üblichen techniken es hat sich natürlich auch komplett verändert,
von der zeit her,
fotografie noch chemisch gewesen ist also klassisch analog zu den heutigen digitalen kameras die wir heute haben die also da auch wahnsinniges leisten wo man sagen müsste,
wenn man früher eine analoge kamera gehabt hat hätte man irgendwie die ganze nacht darauf halten müssen um dieses bild so zu kriegen wie man das jetzt heute irgendwie vielleicht nach ein paar minuten schon auf dem kamerad chip.
Weil er hat die sensoren so dermaßen lichtempfindlich geworden sind.
Genau die kamera tipps sind viel viel besser geworden auch rein von der qualität her von der bildschärfe hat sich da einiges deutlich verbessert das sieht man natürlich auch wenn man,
umgekehrt genauso aufnahmen anschaut,
von profis warten aufgenommen wurden also da gibt's fotos zum beispiel gerade von dem planeten vom mond oder sowas irgendwie von vor zwanzig dreißig jahren die guckt mal an wurde mit einem gewaltig großen teleskop aufgenommen und heute kriegt das ein hobby-astrolog,
mit seinem kleinen teleskop wasser irgendwie im kofferraum vom auto hatte viel viel besser hin.
Das heißt das macht auch so ein bisschen den reiz aus dass anderen eigentlich jetzt durch diese unheimlich gut nachgereifte,
konsumertechnologie die schon so dermaßen in den ehemaligen profibereich reingeht und den teilweise auch überholt eigentlich besser voraussetzungen hat mit einem relativ überschaubaren extra aufwand
auch die sterne noch mitzunehmen.
Ganz genau also.
Da hat man natürlich über die jahre hinweg auch wirklich eine gewaltige entwicklung sehen können einmal sind die sachen viel viel günstiger geworden von den kosten her aber halt eben auch gewaltig viel besser einfach.
Es war schon immer eigentlich so gewesen dass man dinge die man jetzt heute noch nicht vernünftig im laden kaufen kann,
in der profi-gastronomen gehabt hat also es gab sowas wie digitale kameras schon in den achtzigern und anfang der neunziger jahre als amateur zu kaufen also die ersten digitalen kameras,
für amateure teleskope konnte man so mitte der neunziger für ich sage mal bezahlbares geld bekommen wo noch niemand wirklich drüber nachgedacht hat ich kaufe mir jetzt eine digitalkamera für den hausgebrauch das kam erst zehn jahre später.
So das heißt jetzt haben wir eigentlich schon alles zusammen um,
aus mir jetzt so ein so ein amateur astrofotografie zu machen ich habe eine digital kamera so eine ganz normale also normal im sinne von gute kamera mit objektiv anschluss ich habe mir einen,
spiegelteils kob geholt was so mindestens zwanzig zentimeter durchmesser hat und ich habe das ganze auf einem ordentlichen stativ was nicht gleich umfeld welche mal huste und dann bin ich im prinzip schon dabei.
Das einzige was du noch brauchst ist jede menge geduld und frustrationstoleranz weil es wird nicht alles von anfang an funktionieren,
es werden einem viele dinge unterlaufen wo man sagt oh,
was habe ich denn da jetzt für ein unsinn angerichtet und da fehlt mir noch irgendeinen kleinen teil dass ich vergessen habe oder hier ist irgendwas nicht so wie's laufen soll und irgendein technik teil gibt auch immer gerade mal den geist auf wenn es einem gerade nicht in den kram passt.
Aber ich habe die nachführunterricht noch vergessen also ich habe jetzt sozusagen noch keine automatische nachfolger du hast gesagt wenn man es richtig ausrichtet im sinne von also sozusagen auf so einer bewegungsaktiv das heißt ich,
muss quasi das teleskop so ausrichten dass ich so einen leider habe an dem es sich bewegt der dann eben auch der erde oder beziehungsweise der stern bewegung entspricht.
Wenn ich das perfekt gemacht habe dann macht es das von vollautomatisch dann ist doch nichts weiter als motor der das eigentlich einfach nur gleichmäßig.
Ach so also so ein motor ist schon normalerweise dabei.
Der ist ja bei den ganz billigen sachen nicht dabei aber halt ich sag mal bei allem was ab etwa ins level dazu kommt.
Fünfhundert euro die du vorhin genannt hast ok.
Genau der motor an sich ist natürlich dumm der weiß natürlich nicht wenn ich jetzt die aufstellung nicht hundertprozentig genau genug gemacht habe dann dreht der das natürlich einfach umdreht und dreht und dreht und irgendwann dreht er halt vorbei weil die.
Weil weil die weil die richtung nicht hundertprozentig stimmt und da merkt man dann halt wieder diese präzision also es muss alles super präzise gemacht werden und viel präziser als wie ich jetzt mal irgendwie so pie mal daumen machen würde.
Aber wenn man es jetzt richtig fancy wenn sie haben will dann möchte man natürlich ein system haben wo man sagt okay laufe ich hier auf dem berg dann stelle ich mein stativ auf
und das teil findet selber heraus wohin es gerade,
wie spät es ist wo ich mich befinde wie hoch ich bin und wie ich dann entsprechend mitnimmt vielleicht in zwei richtungen arbeitenden motor das korrekt ausrichte.
Ich würde mal sagen so dieses jahr ja ich sprichwörtliche aufblasbare teleskop also auf knopfdruck entfaltet sich alles und,
richtet sich auch selber aus das gibts natürlich bis zu einem gewissen punkt also da gibt's geräte die wir haben eingebautes typs die wissen dann halt eben welches datum welche uhrzeit welcher standort auf den meter genau auf der erde habe ich hier jetzt gerade.
Trotzdem auch solche technik ist natürlich nicht nicht hundert prozent ich sage mal.
Fehler und anfällig also irgendwas kann immer schief gehen und irgendwas wird immer irgendwelche störungen verursachen,
es hilft nix ich muss mich so ein bisschen damit auskennen was das ding eigentlich tut weil sonst habe ich die technik nicht im griff.
Vor allem weiß man dann überhaupt nicht was man tun soll wenn's dann trotzdem nicht funktioniert oder ob man merkt vielleicht noch nicht mal dass es nicht.
Wo wo muss ich sozusagen wo liegt gerade jetzt der fehler wenn irgendwas mal mal festhängt oder sowas wo.
Ich höre da so einen appell raus mit erstmal selber schrauben und dann langsam steigern.
Also sagen wir es mal so das wäre so die der weg den viele leute fahren dass man sagt also sich überhaupt erstmal so eine gewisse grundkenntnisse verschaffen bevor man sich allzu sehr auf die technik verlässt,
ist sicherlich nicht das verkehrteste,
man kann natürlich auch umgekehrt rangehen man kann von vornherein mit der technik anfangen und sich von da auseinander reinarbeiten also zu versuchen zu verstehen ja wie funktioniert denn diese technik eigentlich also was ist jetzt die grundlage von der von der technik die ich da anwende.
Andere leute wiederum sind sind vollkommen glücklich zu sagen ich verlasse mich da jetzt einfach drauf und wenn's nicht funktioniert und funktioniert es halt nicht.
Also ich bin jetzt halt eben beruflich mit teleskopen zu gange die halt eben auch,
solche solche technik sachen haben privat hab ich ein relativ großes teleskop vom durchmesser her vierzig zentimeter was halt reine handbetrieb ist.
Und das auch schon seit über zehn jahren jetzt mittlerweile und bin da völlig glücklich mit und brauche auch nichts anderes.
Ich selber hatte jetzt für mich privat zum beispiel auch nie die motivation schöne astro-fotos zu machen ich habe das mal ausprobiert als ich noch ein teenager war da war das natürlich noch sehr sehr aufwendig weil das halt wirklich noch analog zeitalter war das heißt da gab man irgendwie,
berichteten film ab und kriegt ihr dann den hinterher wieder und von sechsunddreißig bildern waren dann irgendwie drei auf denen irgendwas vernünftig drauf war,
der rest war schrott das ging dann auch irgendwann ins geld und ja dann habe ich so daran die lust verloren und das ist nie wieder mein interessensgebiet geworden jetzt privat einfach schöne bildchen zu machen vom sternenhimmel.
Bei diesen teleskopen sprechen wir jetzt rein von von optischen teleskopen asia das normale sichtbare licht einfangen
gibt es ja noch andere möglichkeiten auch noch andere frequenzbereich auf der erde zu beobachten macht irgendwas da noch sind es irgendwas möglich.
Also es gibt einmal die möglichkeit das ist jetzt allerdings nicht so weit verbreitet infrarot kameras zum beispiel anstoß schließen und die ganz normalen teleskope die man ohnehin schon hat.
Das ist vom erdboden aus so ein bisschen das lässt sich nicht unendlich weit treiben weil diese infrarotstrahlung dann ab einem gewissen punkt besser,
als als wärmestrahlung dann halt von satelliten aus messbar ist und das wiederum liegt nicht mehr in der möglichkeit von amateur astronom was halt es aber natürlich auch noch gibt ist radio anstronaut also radioteleskope haben die profis natürlich auch und es gibt auch eine ganze reihe,
von von kleineren radio schüsseln die halt dann eben an an der tür stand warten beheimatet.
Also wenn wir das radio sagen manchmal jetzt welche frequenzbereich.
Ja da gibt's halt auch wiederum fließende übergänge.
Alles was sehr viel hochfrequenten noch ist als das sichtbare licht.
Also das ist dann so gigaherz bereich sind so die die typischen sachen.
Aber das wird teuer.
Es ist was ganz anderes in dem sinne also man kann da anfangen irgendwie mit einer mit einer ausgemusterte satellitenschüssel die man hat und mit einem passenden empfänger den ich mir an den laptop stöpsel,
radio strahlung von der sonne zu messen also das sind so auch da wieder die ganz einfachen einstiegsmöglichkeiten,
oder ich stelle mir die große zehn meter jagd antenne aufs dach oder dann halt irgendwann das drei meter oder fünf meter radioteleskope in den garten.
Wird gemacht oder könnte man nur theoretisch machen.
Kann man tun machen auch einige leute aber natürlich deutlich weniger jetzt halt eben als wie sich ein optisches teleskop zu kaufen.
Weil kann man ja nicht fotografieren und so schön sind ja so sein mehr oder weniger abstrakte beobachtung die man ja dann noch visualisieren müsste.
Ja also auch da ist halt wieder so ein bisschen interessenslage also das sind jetzt leute die sowas machen zum beispiel die kommen häufig aus der funkamateur gegend haben auch so ein interesse halt eben an amateurfunk und sagen das verbinde ich jetzt mit meinem interesse an astronomie und mache jetzt radio anstronaut.
Und.
Oder halt einfach auch sagen ja ich ich mache sowas gerne klar schöne bildchen kommen dabei nicht raus aber das wäre jetzt halt auch wieder so ein so ein bereich der amateure wo man versuchen kann halt was zu machen wo man profi-gastronomen mit unterstützen kann.
Was könnte man da so beobachtet pulsar oder.
Das ist in der radioaktiv im amateurbereich alles gar nicht so einfach denn da gewinnt tatsächlich weniger die masse als auch die größe also je mehr,
spielt halt wirklich sehr sehr stark mit ein das,
um messungen zu machen halt große teleskope wichtig sind wir zum beispiel in deutschland dass das große profite äpfel berg da bei bonn mit hundert metern durchmesser wo die leute damit,
loslegen und die profis fangen also irgendwie so unter dreißig meter gar nicht an und sowas hat man natürlich als amateur normalerweise nicht das ist dann tatsächlich viel zu.
Passt nicht so richtig auf den balkon auch.
Nicht so richtig ja.
Aber kann man dann trotzdem in irgendeiner form sich in so ein netzwerk einklinken wo man dann sozusagen eine von von von vielen tausenden von antenne ist.
Könnte man rein theoretisch gibt's aber nicht wirklich also da sind die profi-gastronomen die sowas machen ja zufrieden mit dem was sie da haben sage ich mal so da ist es dann nämlich tatsächlich so wenn ich so ein radio,
teleskop verbund haben möchte da kommt's weniger auf die teleskope an als dass man die wirklich auf die atomzeitalter genau halt präzise zusammenschneiden kann also da ist die die zeitliche,
korrelation der daten sehr sehr wichtig und so eine atomuhr kann sich halt auch nicht mehr jeder hobby-astrolog leisten.
Ja
Ja das ist das ist da dann so ein bisschen so der haken an der sache.
Ich sehe schon dann schauen wir doch vielleicht mal darauf was bisher auch schon mal geleistet worden ist was sind denn so so dinge die mit diesen ganzen optischen.
Teleskopen erfolgreich beobachtet worden ist wo wo auch vielleicht diese zuarbeit in den profibereich gut funktioniert hat.
Es gibt eine ganze reihe von projekten halt eben tatsächlich,
wo sich leute auch mit verschiedenen interessensgebiete dann halt einfach reingehauen haben wo irgendwann mal profi-gastronomen gesagt haben hey ihr könnte ich jetzt hilfe gebrauchen einfach weil ich mehr daten brauche also sehr sehr schönes beispiel halt eben,
was besonders attraktiv gewesen ist für leute die halt vorher hauptsächlich sich darauf.
Konzentriert haben schöne bilder zu machen ging von mehreren gruppen auch wieder von von profi-gastronomen aus die sagen wir wollen galaxien sichtbar machen,
jetzt nicht einfach so wie sie auf einem schnell gemachten bild sichtbar werden jetzt halt so wie die spirale halt eben des hauses der astronomie zum beispiel sondern wir wollen gucken wie ob diese spirale noch viel viel weiter rausreichen als wie man sie auf den ersten blick sehen kann,
oder wenn diese galaxie halt eben zum beispiel mal vor längerer zeit in der begegnung mit einer anderen galaxie.
Gehabt hat gibt's da irgendwelche störungen kann man das noch nachweisen gibt's da irgendwie ganz schwach sichtbare strukturen die diese beiden galaxien nach ihrer kollision miteinander verbinden und sowas,
ja die fotografen nehmen dann halt ihre teleskope braucht man halt normalerweise gar nicht so sehr die großen teleskope sondern irgendwas mittelgroßes reicht da völlig und dann wird einfach drauf los belichtet,
ja die die bilder werden dann hinterher halt eben mit.
Den techniken ausgereizt die man verwenden würde um wirklich einfach den kontrast hoch zu drehen um zu gucken kann ich da noch mehr sehen als wie vorher auf den aufnahmen die vorher von dem himmels objekt hatte.
Da rauszuholen und da gibt's eine ganze reihe,
von von solchen galaxien die man damit mittlerweile untersucht hat wo man halt dann eben gerade über diese galaxien zusammenstößen
mehr herausgefunden hat dass man sagt hat also da ist jetzt hier so ein so ein bogen sichtbar geworden er hat mir gesagt also diese galaxien die haben sich vorher so und so einander gedreht und da hat sich so ein solcher,
gezeiten schweif nennt man das dann ausgebildet,
und versucht dann halt eben darüber auch mehr zu lernen dann von profi seite wiederum ja wie wie haben sich die galaxien früher verhalten weil das ist dann ja halt teilweise auch schon eine ganze weile in der vergangenheit zurück dass es passiert ist.
Also dieses dieses meer sichtbar machen auf bildern das ist ein ist ein ganz häufiger aspekt den man den man machen.
Ja ich klicke mal macht sie auch eins nicht so richtig klar man es gibt natürlich riesige professionelle teleskop
voll davon es wird wie fleißig nachgebaut das riesen teleskop kommt jetzt klar das sind dinge die können natürlich alles in einer detail
tiefe beobachten liken aber vor dem gibt's halt auch nur ein paar und die können natürlich zu jedem zeitpunkt auch immer nur,
an eine stelle gucken
der vorteil der ganzen amateur astronomie und astrofotografie szene ist jetzt diesen halt viele und wenn man sozusagen diese kraft gemeinsam nutzt hat man einfach sehr viele augen auf sehr vielen objekten in einer sehr
großen zeit oder sehr eine sehr feine zeit,
und das macht sozusagen andere beobachtungen überhaupt erst möglich die sich so auf der professionellen ebene überhaupt nicht organisieren diesen weil man diese zeit nie bekommen würde auf den an den anderen teleskopen weil
das kostet auch eine ganze menge geld im betrieb und das muss irgendwo herkommen und das kriegt man da nicht zugeteilt sich das richtig.
Das letztendlich bei vielen sachen der der entscheidende aspekt also die zahl der wirklich großen teleskope die profis nutzen lässt sich an zwei händen abzählen.
Deren betrieb ist halt letztendlich doch irgendwo kostenintensiv das heißt man optimiert da so ein bisschen wofür brauche ich so ein teleskop wirklich bei vielen sachen reicht halt dann eben auch ein teleskop eine nummer kleiner oder halt eben,
von der größe wie sie halt eben auch die amateure zur verfügung haben aber das dafür in großen mengen also es gibt eine ganze reihe von dingen da muss ich jetzt,
kein acht meter teleskop draufhalten ein ein beispiel zum beispiel wäre sowas wie es gibt ja mittlerweile eine ganze reihe von,
extra solaren planeten mehrere tausend stück und wenn man die jetzt überwacht,
zum beispiel die sogenannten transit also wo man den planeten vor dem stern vorbeiziehen hat von der erde ausgesehen und dann gibt es eine ganz leichte verdunkelung dann kann man das einmal machen dann sieht man das.
Wenn man das der zweite mal macht dann kann man sagen okay ja das andere war jetzt vielleicht nicht ein messfeier sondern es ist tatsächlich echt und wenn man das das dritte mal macht,
sagt hier ja zeitliche abstand passt also kann ich mir langsam aber sicher sicher sein dass er da ist entdeckung tag nächsten,
wenn ich das jetzt langfristig über mehrere jahre überwache dann weiß ich irgendwann auch sowas wie ja bleibt dieser zeitliche umlauf wirklich stabil oder ändert sich vielleicht diese planeten bahn,
über einen zeitraum von mehreren jahren hinweg dann merke ich und wenn sowas passiert dann weiß man auch sowas wie ja da könnte noch ein anderer planet sein den ich vorher noch nicht kannte der aber dieses andere schon bekannte planetensystem stört also,
solche messungen zu machen wirklich jahrelang halt dann irgendwie auf so einen so einen schon bekannten transit planeten zu gucken.
Wo sich dann eventuell herausstellen könnte ja da ist noch einer das ist ein brotlose geschäft weil es halt eben so viele gibt.
In der masse dann doch wieder interessant ist wo man einfach sagt wenn da jemand mal wirklich sorgfältig lange hingucken kann,
dann wird es gut und da werden diese transitland dann wiederum nur ein beispiel von dem was man machen kann also irgendwas wo man,
eine lange liste von eigentlich spannenden kandidaten für etwas hätte wo aber bei weitem nicht jeder der jeder von diesen kandidaten sich dann auch wirklich als spannendes objekt entpuppen wird.
Alles war der quasi auch professionellen oder angehenden astronomen
erlauben in dem moment wo man eben so eine amateur szene mit welcher motivation,
immer für sich gewinnt und sagst so hier ich habe eine coole idee dass vielleicht auch mein promotions arbeit und so weiter aber ich würde halt niemals die beobachtung dafür bekommen hält also das aber trotzdem für für ein interessantes experiment
habt ihr bock da irgendwie mitzumachen und man organisiert sich das dann sozusagen
was warum er man für intensive dann findet dafür begeisterung auszulösen ich meine aber schon gesehen so ok für viele
ist es sozusagen überhaupt schon begeisterung an sich so
bei so einem prozess dabei zu sein auch sagen wir mal ein konkretes ziel zu haben weil ich denke man ist auch sicherlich oft so in dieser situation so ah okay jetzt habe ich so ein tolles
teleskop hier rumstehen das habe ich auch irgendwie zwei jahre damit verbracht das ordentlich einzustellen aber ob ich mir jetzt irgendwie alpha centauri b oder wie riegel hast nicht gesehen anschaue.
Ja
warum so aber in dem moment wo man so von außen so ein bedarf getriggert bekommst und sieht so ja hier als ich bisschen mir jetzt unbedingt mal diese sternen gruppe mal genauer anschauen
dann hat man ja sozusagen auch gleich automatisch eine ganz andere motivation ganz anderes ziel oder auch einfach so eine automatische vorgabe mit so okay dann mache ich halt das wenn da jemand was anderes davon hat weil ich schärfe jetzt hier eigentlich nur meine skills um überhaupt sozusagen hier besser zu werden indem was ich.
Bisher ohnehin schon ganz gut getan habe und es hat dann eben auch noch den benefit das eben dann die,
dass jemand das sozusagen auch noch zentral verwertet die daten dann eben auch tatsächlich für irgendetwas benutzt werden.
Wollen wir natürlich schon sagen muss also es gibt eine ganze reihe von leuten und vermutlich sogar die überzahl der leute die einfach sagt also ich mache das für mich also meine motivation ist tatsächlich,
meine bildbearbeitung fähigkeiten soweit rauszukriegen dass ich jetzt ein super tolles bild rausbekomme.
Aber wie gesagt es gibt halt eben auch viele die sagen ja vor greater good also ich möchte hier halt auch wirklich was wissenschaftlich beitragen zum beispiel meine meine sachen die ich gemacht die sollen zu irgendwas nur zu sein,
leute gibt es natürlich auch und die suchen sich dann halt eben ihre nische die vielleicht gerade auch zu dem equipment passt was sie ohnehin schon haben.
Was sind denn noch so andere dinge die gemacht werden also wenn schon angedeutet so spektrums kopie ist an sich ein großes ding da kann man sich ja dann im prinzip auch daran beteiligen.
Zum beispiel wobei spektrums kopie als als technik halt wiederum etwas ist was schon sehr sehr speziell ist in der amateur und was halt auch relativ aufwendig ist,
wo man halt letztendlich auch wieder eine kamera braucht und ein ordentliches teleskop und passenden unterbau dazu,
die auswertung ist es dann hinterher wenn ich die selber mache die da dann teilweise halt auch noch wieder richtig aufwendig werden kann und auch wieder mal was ganz anderes darstellt als wie wenn ich jetzt hinterher die bilder bearbeite weil ich da dann halt eben auch richtig wissenschaftliche techniken anwenden muss,
und dann ja mich teilweise wirklich mit mit software rumschlagen muss die jetzt eigentlich für profi-gastronomen gedacht war und mich da dann entsprechend reinfuchsen muss in die sachen.
Aber dass man einfach so rohdaten zu träger wird ist es so weniger eine option.
Gibt es auch.
Letztendlich ist es halt aber so wenn man sein gerät kennt üblicherweise ist es besser wenn man die daten auch selber auswertet unter denn die fertigen ergebnisse sozusagen abliefert ist meistens einfacher.
Aber umgekehrt kann man natürlich halt selber auch sagen als jemand der dann solche wissenschaftlichen daten sammelt zum beispiel ich möchte alle rohdaten haben und werte die dann alle auf die gleiche art und weise aus also da gibt es zwei verschiedene ansätze dann irgendwo auch kann man sich genauso überlegen,
aber normalerweise ist natürlich schon auch so dass die wenigsten leute sich damit zufriedengeben jetzt einfach zu sagen aber ich liefere da jetzt irgendwas ab und weiß gar nicht was hinterher dabei rauskommt.
Ja
Ich hatte hier vor einiger zeit bei raum zeigen schönes gespräch mit stefan jordan über den neuen sternen katalog,
der ja jetzt verfügbar ist das natürlich dann vielleicht auch eine schöne vorgabe dass man sagen kann okay jetzt.
Weiß man von bestimmten sternen auch schon die spektrum komische beschaffenheit also man hat da schon mal mit profi equipment draufgeschaut jetzt schnappe ich mir einfach mal denselben stern und versuche mal genau diese messung
so nachzuvollziehen daran kann man ja dann sozusagen ganz gut eine fähigkeiten dann auch schleifen oder.
Ja wobei ich sagen würde meistens ist es eher andersrum also.
Es gibt häufig relativ spezielle themen die die leute dann irgendwo reizen also wenn man sagt ich mache jetzt einfach irgendwie spektrum kopie und guck mal ob ich das genauso gut hinkriege das ist eher was so wie wie der astrofotografie arbeiten würde,
gerade so in der spektrums kopie würde man dann eher sagen also es gibt diese interessante,
stern klasse wo man jetzt sagen würde da sollte man möglichst viele objekte die vorher noch niemand genauer angeguckt halt mal mal eben untersuchen vielleicht auch langfristig untersuchen und da dann wirklich halt einfach auch was neues beitragen ohne dass man vorher weiß was rauskommen soll.
Gibt's noch so ergebnisse die aus der amateur szene heraus erzeugt wurden die vielleicht hier noch erwähnenswert wären.
Es gibt eine eine ganze reihe von sachen halt eben immer in in verschiedenen bereichen typisches beispiel wo halt eben zum beispiel auch die die amateure und die profis sehr sehr gut zusammenarbeiten ist der bereich kleinen planeten also asteroiden,
die szene hat sich ziemlich gewandelt in letzter zeit weil es da im profibereich eine ganze reihe von teleskopen gibt,
den himmel durch mustern also sprich ein bild machen teleskopen stückchen weiter rücken nächstes bild machen,
teleskop weiter rücken und so weiter bis dann halt einmal der komplette himmel abgegrast ist,
ja diese teleskope machen die allermeisten entdeckungen und davon halt eben auch gleich den ganzen schlag,
bei diesem entdeckungen die da gemacht werden also wirklich einmal weise da fallen dann halt häufig mal.
Spannende objekte auf wo man sagen würde ey da würde es sich lohnen genauer hinzugucken also ist das jetzt vielleicht einen kleinen planet der demnächst auf die erde stürzt oder ist das einer der ganz weit draußen ist und der der nächste,
der eigentlich in wirklichkeit der nächste interstellaren komet ist oder sowas,
auch da gilt dann wieder ja die profi-gastronomen haben nicht genug teleskopen nicht genug ressourcen um all diese möglichen spannenden kandidaten anzugucken,
aus dem heuhaufen sozusagen die stecknadeln rauszufischen und dann auch noch die eine stecknadel die halt wirklich spannend ist dann raus zu fusseln,
das ist dann etwas was häufig die amateure machen die dann wiederum diese spannenden kandidaten halt eben auch angucken und ihre messungen dann zentral abliefern und sagen hey der hat sich als normal völlig normales objekt entpuppt nachdem ich das zweite und das dritte mal hin.
Aber es ist auch ganz schön dunkel.
Ja also es ist so dass man da jetzt vielleicht nicht mehr mit dem ganz kleinen teleskop was machen kann,
aber eben auch schon so mit mittelgroßen teleskopen so ab dreißig zentimeter durchmesser aufwärts kann man da halt gut was machen da gibt's halt eben zum beispiel dann halt auch aus deutschland nach wie vor entdeckungen also das halt da,
wirklich auch trotzdem noch neue entdeckungen auch von kometen zum beispiel einfach vom balkon von irgendjemandem erfolgen können das passiert nach wie vor ist zwar selten aber,
ist halt etwas was tatsächlich auf genauso gemacht wird und dann halt eben ja also dieses diese spannende zweitverwertung dass man sagt also hier sind hier sind spannende sachen,
schon entdeckt sind solange ich weiß wo ich in etwa suchen muss ist es dann natürlich auch viel viel leichter solche sachen wiederzufinden auch mit kleinerem equipment.
Was ich auch noch gehört hatte ist das auch so in der supernova nach beobachtung amateur rundum zum einsatz kommen.
Genau auch da ist es halt letztendlich wieder das gleiche prinzip also es gibt diese durch musterung teleskope in dem fall sind es denn jetzt andere üblicherweise als als wir für die asteroiden,
aber so da paloma transit factory zum beispiel wäre da so ein ein beispiel die halt solche messdaten liefern in dem falle von helligkeiten von himmels objekten von denen man jetzt vielleicht noch gar nicht wusste dass es irgendwas spannendes.
Aber irgendwas was man vorher schon katalogisiert hatte und da passiert jetzt irgendwas ganz dramatisches oder sowas also hier ist jetzt ein stern explodiert und dann gilt jetzt auch wieder.
Da müssen wir jetzt gucken da müssen wir jetzt die nächsten wochen und monate draufhalten und möglichst viele helligkeits messungen über diesen zeitraum hinweg erhalten,
oder vielleicht sogar auch spektren dazu zum beispiel haben und ja auch da dann dann wieder das kapazitätsproblem wo die amateure dann halt einfach.
Helligkeits messungen machen können oder eben auch spektren messen.
Schönes beispiel ist jetzt zum beispiel halt auch sternenbild golze war ordentlich in den medien in letzter zeit mit.
Ungewöhnlich licht schwach geworden oder sowas,
da hat man die kuriose situation dass dieser stern viel zu hell ist für die für die allgemeinen profitables kobe und ihre messinstrumente die die haben das heißt die ganzen
sinnvollen messungen die dann wirklich auf die nachkommastelle genau gesagt haben ah jetzt ist aber schluss mit dem helligkeits abfall von dem stand und die helligkeit steigt wieder an die stammen alle von amateuren.
Also peter götze ist ja dunkler geworden im club letzten oktober zwanzig neunzehn ist das so aufgefallen wo dann immer dunkler mal dunkler bis dezember januar und man hat sozusagen schon.
Na ja man hat nicht unbedingt vermute aber es stand sozusagen zur debatte so okay stimme jetzt kurz vor der supernova weil das ist sozusagen mit diesem stern irgendwann passieren wird ist klar nur vielleicht nicht unbedingt morgen sondern halt so ein astronomisches morgen sowas was ich so
millionen jahre dauern oder ein paar hunderttausend jahre ich weiß ich ganz genau was da die einschätzung gerade so ist jetzt stellt sich halt eher raus.
Ist wahrscheinlich nur ein großer staub nebel der jetzt auch schon wieder langsam verzieht also in dem moment wo wir sprechen ist glaube ich sind die drei tore für die helligkeit von peter gottes geht schon wieder so nach oben also alles so halbe aufregung
aber der lässt sich dann sozusagen extrem gut beobachten.
So was zum beispiel das etwas was relativ leicht zu machen ist wenn man das super genau machen will dann muss man natürlich halt auch aber wieder,
wissen was man da machen kann aber tatsächlich ist das jetzt zum beispiel halt auch was was man einfach mit bloßem auge wirklich sehen konnte wenn man da einfach sich erinnert hat ja wie sagen der letztes jahr im winter aus.
Dann wusste man halt der der stern war genauso hell wie der andere helle sterne riegel im orion und das ist ja jetzt bei weitem ich das konnte jeder der ich sag mal.
Systematisch einfach nur mit bloßem auge den himmel angeguckt hat sofort erkennen und dementsprechend ist das halt etwas was die ganze sache vom prinzip her halt eben auch greifbar für jedermann gemacht hat.
Über den rest kann man so ein bisschen streiten also vieles vieles um die ganze geschichte war natürlich medien hip also die profis wussten eigentlich letztendlich von vornherein schon der stern hat sowas früher schon mal gemacht das ist jetzt nichts ungewöhnliches,
klar könnte uns auch vor der nase weg explodieren aber die wahrscheinlichkeit dass er das macht es halt eben dann doch nicht so ganz super hoch,
dementsprechend man hat eigentlich jetzt nicht unbedingt damit gerechnet dass er uns direkt vor der nase weg explodiert.
Aber es hat zumindest ein schönes phänomen weil man hier doch ein verhältnismäßig kurzen zeiträumen extreme änderungen sehen konnte.
Der witz ist natürlich die veränderung als solches selber hat man gar nicht so richtig gesehen das sternbild orion ist was was man in den sommermonaten nicht so wirklich gut erkennen kann,
und was halt eben dann auch im im frühling für uns ja aus der sicht verschwindet es halt einfach ein typisches winter sternbild und ja letztendlich.
Ist das sozusagen wer wer letztes jahr geguckt hat und wer dieses jahr guckt der sieht den unterschied sozusagen wenn man systematisch genug geguckt hat dass man weiß wie der sternbild orion aussieht dann weiß man auch der eine stern sollte aber viel viel heller sein.
Tatsächlich ist es so dass das eine ganze reihe von leuten die halt einfach natur beobachter gewesen sind die sich gar nicht so sehr halt eben jetzt mit der astronomie super.
Ausgiebig beschäftigt haben dann aber tatsächlich aufgefallen ist dass sie gesagt haben hey das standbild und das kenne ich aber anders dass irgendwas faul und.
Sowas kann dann halt leute natürlich auch wieder genauso halt dazu bringen sich mit sowas näher zu beschäftigen oder halt eben generell mit was kann denn da oben eigentlich überhaupt alles passieren.
Jetzt merkt man schon du bist du im im thema drin kommst wahrscheinlich irgendwie morgens aus dem haus rausschossen nach oben deckel so aus mit dem stern los
ja weil man das so so ein bisschen alles verkatert hat im kopf dann dann geht das natürlich schnell jetzt ist das wollen wir mal für jeden der einsteigt so alles ja sehr die fuß und ungeordnet,
jetzt gibt's ja ein paar richtig nette apps auch für die telefone mit dem man so diese kartografie schon mal ganz gut erlernen kann.
Ich weiß nicht ob du da irgendwas empfehlen würdest für den einstieg weil es kann ja schon durchaus eine hilfe sein oder.
Auf jeden fall und da sollte man natürlich tatsächlich auch einfach nutzen was die technologie heute so hergibt also.
Die entsprechenden apps fürs handy die benutzen alle die die sensoren die da verbaut sind neigung sensoren kompass und sowas alles was das handy dann halt eben hat das heißt ich kann einfach das telefon an irgendeiner stelle des himmels richten,
dann zeig mir die dazu passende karte halt an mit name ja was ist denn das wirklich wie heißt denn das ist das ein planet ist es ein stern oder wenn ich ein teleskop in die gegend richte was es da noch so in der ecke zu sehen,
da gibt's eine ganze reihe tatsächlich von bekannten apps für fürs handy ziemlich verbreitet ist zum beispiel sky safari.
Gibt auch welche die sind kostenlos gibt welche die kosten ein paar euro teilweise auch ein paar mehr euro.
Einige zum beispiel halt dann wiederum wo man das handy auch direkt ans teleskop wiederum per bluetooth anschließen kann und dann wiederum sagen kann ja ich tippe hier irgendwo auf das handy hin während ich das da oben an den an den himmel halte und dann fällt mir das teleskop dahin.
Talking das ist ja schön ja.
Überhaupt so software was gibt's denn an an an software system oder auch websites die einem bei dieser ganzen astronomischen beobachtung helfen können die so typischerweise zum einsatz kommen.
Also gerade wenn man überhaupt erstmal den,
einstieg haben will dann kann man so was wie so ein sternkarte programm natürlich auch einfach auf dem computer benutzen da gibt's eine ganze reihe von von also software die auch wirklich,
gut ist aber trotzdem nichts kostet.
Sehr sehr bekannt ist der larion natürlich halt einfach als sternkarte programm was den sternenhimmel auch wirklich so darstellt wie ich ihn sehe und was ich für für jedes betriebssystem bekomme,
fürs handy kostet so ein paar euro aber für einen computer kann ich das einfach so runterladen und dann halt eben sehen wann es welcher sternhimmel zu sehen,
kann das auch beliebig umschalten und mich dann so ein bisschen orientieren und das ist dann halt eben natürlich auch eine schöne einstiegshilfe früher hätte man sowas ganz klassisch.
Analog gemacht macht man heutzutage natürlich teilweise auch noch einfach mit einer sogenannten drehbahn sternkarte die man dann passend einstellt aber das kann der computer natürlich auch alles digital übernehmen und einem dann noch so ein paar zusatzfunktionen geben wie.
Die dinge die auf der sternkarte nicht verzeichnet sind dann trotzdem mit anzeigen.
Was gibt's noch so.
Ja dann würde man halt weitermachen mit allerlei programm die einem jetzt zum beispiel das teleskop steuern.
Was teilweise zum beispiel schon auch so programme wieder salarium dann wiederum mit übernehmen können also ich habe kann dann so mein meine teleskop montiert die das teleskop bewegt dann halt,
direkt anschließend per laptop an so ein sternkarte programm und dann sagen ja fahren wir da hin,
steuere ich meine kameras die dann halt eben die bilder aufnehmen habe noch weitere hilfsprogramme dann halt eben um die nachführunterricht zu kontrollieren als solche dinge und es geht dann weiter halt eben auch,
über die bildauswertung die bildbearbeitung da gibt's spezialprogramme,
auch der verwendet sowas wie photoshop aber meistens eher erst im letzten schritt und die vorherigen schritte in der bildbearbeitung die nehmen,
andere programme her teilweise dann halt auch kostenpflichtige programme die aber so gut sind dass sie trotzdem weiter verbreitet sind wieder wie pics in zeit zum beispiel,
aber eben auch einfach kostenfreie programme kleine programme fit work,
die bilder überlagern oder bilder halt einfach grundlegende funktionen in der bearbeitung übernehmen können für solche astro aufnahmen.
Die programme sind dann zum guten teil halt eben auch von amateur selber programmiert weil man dann halt eben auch.
Wenn man sowas selber macht natürlich weiß ja so die funktion die jetzt so ein bild bearbeitungsweise wie photoshop eben hat,
die ist da zwar grundlegend drinne aber so in genau der form wie man sie jetzt nochmal ein bisschen spezieller haben müsste mit noch besseren einstellmöglichkeiten,
hätte man dann vielleicht gerne aber die bieten diese programme auch als plugins nicht so richtig oder nicht so komfortabel und deshalb gibt's dann halt eben auch so diese spezielleren programme daneben.
Damit schon alle wichtigen genannt die man mal gehört haben sollte.
Also das sind so die die weiter verbreitet sind leute die jetzt beispielsweise aufnahmen von planeten machen würden andere software verwenden denn die technik um planeten zu fotografieren ist eine andere als wie wenn man jetzt zum beispiel,
galaxien und gashebel fotografieren möchte da würde man ja auf lange belichtungszeiten setzen auf die überlagerung,
von mehreren langen berichteten einzelaufgaben bei planeten oder auch eben zum beispiel beim mondkrater oder details auf der sonne zum beispiel,
würde man eine strategie fahren dass man einen anderen typ von kameras hat die,
videos aufnehmen und zwar videos die möglichst viele bilder pro sekunde machen die himmels objekte sind ja auch so hell dass ich da jetzt keine langen belichtungszeiten brauche,
dementsprechend nimmt man videos auf im rohr vom markt mit möglichst vielen einzelbilder mit möglichst hoher bild rate,
und dann gibt es software die mehr oder weniger vollautomatisch dann halt eben aus diesen videos die schärfsten einzelbilder rausfischen.
Dann nur noch diese schärfsten einzelbilder zur überlagerung zusammensucht die auch passend zurecht rückt jetzt zum beispiel oder vielleicht sogar,
entzerrt wenn die nämlich durch atmosphärische turbulenzen also störungen halt einfach die das bild so leicht verwahren lässt,
dann noch zusätzlich mit ausgleichen kann auch da gilt wieder diese software ist teilweise sehr sehr komplex.
Welcher surfarena jetzt konkret.
Da gibt es programme beispielsweise wie wie autos dackel hat was solche videos.
Auswerten kann dann gibt es auch aufnahmeprogramm es halt eben zuerst die man die man da verwenden kann sehr sehr bekannt feier capture in dem falle.
Also all all diese programme sind halt auch wieder teilweise auch eben sogar von deutschen amateur halt eben programmiert und der community dann auch frei zur verfügung gestellt.
Stromert triker hat mir das schon.
Das ist ein ein programm was die kleinen planeten beobachter verwenden um ihre aufnahmen auszuwerten,
hat reiche amateur herbert rap grammies halt eben für für diese auswertung da geht's darum die positionen der sterne sehr sehr genau zu bestimmen also im prinzip sowas ähnliches wie das was der geier satelliten macht.
Relativ zu den sternen die da im bild sind da fließt also dieser geier katalog,
jetzt möchte ich anhand der sterne die im bild sind sagen wo ganz exakt auf die nachkommastelle genau ist denn mein asteroid in dem bild,
das übernimmt dann in dem falle halt so ein programm wo ich dann halt eben die asteroiden die vorher vielleicht noch niemand kannte auf dem bild dann halt auswerten kann das ist eine software die ist so gut dass sie halt eben auch von dem profi-gastronomen eingesetzt wird.
Vielleicht so zum abschluss nochmal.
Was bewegt denn die amateurseele welche probleme gibt es da ich könnte mir vorstellen dass bei dieser ganzen beobachtung das thema lichtverschmutzung relativ wichtiger bereich zu sein scheint.
Nun ist es natürlich so wir sind hier in deutschland in einem land das dicht besiedelt ist und ja natürlich ist lichtverschmutzung für uns alle ein problem wenn ich mich in einer million statt,
irgendwo mitten in der stadt stelle sehe ich in einer klaren nacht vielleicht nur eine handvoll sterne das führt im übrigen auch tatsächlich dazu,
das natürlich ja die den leuten der sternhimmel viel viel weniger bewusst ist und dass auch viel weniger leute ihren weg überhaupt in die gastronomie finden weil sie diesen anblick gar nicht mehr so richtig wahrnehmen,
ja aber diejenigen die halt eben ihren weg in das hobby gefunden haben die wissen natürlich aber auch zum beispiel von reisen an an andere orte wo es halt eben besser ist,
vielleicht auch sogar tatsächlich reisen die man speziell mit dem zweck unternimmt halt eben mal wohin zu kommen wo der sternhimmel wirklich viel besser ist als da wo man üblicherweise ist das ist halt eben besser gehen würde,
tatsächlich gibt es eine ganze reihe von leuten die sich auf wiederum genau dafür engagieren dass man halt sagt also bitte,
überflüssige beleuchtung abschalten gucken dass lampen halt auch wirklich nur das beleuchten was auch wirklich beleuchtet werden muss und nicht unabsichtlich in den himmel strahlen und sowas.
Weil es natürlich auch ein umweltaspekt hat und schädlich für.
Tier und vermutlich eben ja auch den menschen ist wenn man einfach zu viel licht hat wo eigentlich kein licht sein sollte.
Die astronomie die dadurch behindert wird ist da irgendwo nur ein aspekt vielleicht auch gar nicht mal der wichtigste dann ja eben obwohl man natürlich tatsächlich sagen kann also einfach,
dieser blick an den sternenhimmel hat in früheren zeiten halt eben die menschliche kultur geprägt hat unseren kalender bestimmt und wenn wir jetzt keine sterne mehr sehen dann wird's irgendwann dann fehlt uns was irgendwo auch.
Aber natürlich halt eben auch zu sagen ich kann ich kann das nicht mehr machen was ich hier eigentlich gerne machen würde das was die profi-gastronomen letztendlich dazu getrieben hat ihre sternwarte,
in den fernsten ecken der welt aufzubauen wo halt eben keine größeren ansiedlungen weit und breit sind das ist halt etwas was der amateur nicht einfach so machen kann und der muss dann halt stattdessen auf die barrikaden gehen und sagen ey leute seid doch mal ein bisschen sparsamer mit eurem strahler hier.
Es gibt ja mittlerweile auch ein paar vorgaben eu-vorgaben wie denn sozusagen licht überhaupt ausgerichtet werden soll also da tut sich so ein bisschen was das hat so ein bisschen was mit den frequenz anteilen von den lampen die aufgestellt werden zu tun also sozusagen blauanteil gesenkt wird etcetera womit man
schon mal eine ganze menge machen kann oder eben auch so die ausrichtung der lampen mit,
geregelt werden da kann man dann sozusagen aber auch lokal in seiner eigenen gemeinde auch mal vorstellig werden und auf solche aspekte auch mal hinweisen.
Das machen viele leute aus der amateur schöne natürlich tatsächlich auch mal mit mehr mal mit weniger erfolg also einige einige lokalpolitiker sind da auf dem ohr einfach schlicht und ergreifend taub,
andere sind da für die sache durchaus zugänglich und es gibt ja tatsächlich auch eine ganze reihe von gemeinden die sich da dann,
die auch den nutzen der sache erkannt haben wo man dann sagt ja wir wir nehmen das als als eine motivation auch für tourismus jetzt zum beispiel um leute herzulocken zu sagen hey wir haben hier den unberührten sternhimmel hier könnt ihr die sterne sehen.
Die stirnpartie.
Sterne oder halt eben auch generell einfach regionen wo man wo man auf diesen astro tourismus setzt.
Tourismus ist.
Das ist es tatsächlich nicht nur hier bei uns in deutschland.
Es ist tatsächlich so dass das nicht nur interessant ist für für leute die ja ihr teleskopen raus aus der großstadt nehmen wollen sondern halt auch wirklich einfach für leute die die insgesamt dann halt eben einfach.
Die natur mehr wahrnehmen wollen also nicht nur nicht nur leute die die wirklich dezidierte hobby-astrolog sind sondern leute die einfach sagen.
Hey ich möchte das mal sehen und die dann aber wiederum wenn sie in solchen sternen parks und sowas dann sind und da glaub machen dann halt aber wiederum auch zurückgreifen auf die amateure und zu sagen hey ja was das was ich hier alles sehe was ist denn das überhaupt zeigt mir das doch mal.
Warst du schon mal in so einem sternen park.
Ich war schon mal in so einem sterntag allerdings nicht zum urlaub machen,
ich hatte da dann immer mal wieder regelmäßig die die gelegenheit auch einfach beruflich an alle möglichen orte zu kommen wo man dann halt natürlich weiß dass der sternenhimmel einfach schön ist,
kann das auch so völlig ohne urlaub in in so diktierten sternen parks genießen.
Auf urlaub wollte ich jetzt gar nicht hinaus aber ich wollte mal so ein gefühl dafür bekommt wie unterschiedlich ist es denn also wie wie groß ist denn der unterschied.
Gewaltig,
also das das krasseste beispiel was mir persönlich passiert ist folgendes ist jetzt schon ein paar jahre her ich war zu studienzeiten also beziehungsweise als ich noch noch doktorandin war dann halt eben auch eine wissenschaftlichen tagung in los angeles gewesen,
im anschluss sind wir mit kollegen einfach dann halt so roadtripmäßig dann halt mit einem mietauto unterwegs gewesen doch für eine woche.
Ja und dann sind wir da abends halt einfach noch unterwegs gewesen und da kalifornischen wüste,
ich saß hinten in diesem mietwagen und die scheiben hinten waren verdunkelt und ich habe durch die verdunkelte scheiben durch die andromedagalaxie am himmel gesehen,
habe dann gesagt ey leute haltet mal bitte an wir sollten mal aussteigen und das mal ohne verdunkelte scheiben angucken und das hat einen dann förmlich erschlagen.
Was man da oben himmel gesehen hat wirklich in dieser einsamen wüstenlandschaft einfach.
Und das wurde auch im sterntag in deutschland funktionieren.
Ja vielleicht nicht ganz so gut es kommt auch so ein bisschen auf den auf den jeweiligen standort drauf an
aber der unterschied von einfach schon aus einer aus einer größeren stadt heraus eben einfach dann aufs land zu fahren der macht sich ja schon bemerkbar und wenn man dann noch in der gegend ist wo wirklich systematisch drauf geachtet wird dass die,
straßenlaub wirklich nur nach unten leuchten dass keine überflüssige werbebereich ist und sowas dann wird die sache natürlich nochmal besser.
Eine andere debatte der lichtverschmutzung ist ja durch die jüngste ausbringung der starlink satelliten auch gestartet worden ich hatte hier vor ein paar sendungen dass auch schon mal,
an thematisiert als wir uns über space-x das unternehmen was das jetzt macht unterhalten haben,
ich denke mal du hast ein andere perspektive drauf als die basics mitarbeiter.
Ja das ist natürlich ein thema was sowohl profi wie auch amateure auf die palme bringen kann.
Unter dem profi-gastronomen.
Auf der einen seite natürlich zum beispiel die astro fotografen die dann halt auf irgendwann auf absehbare zeit hinweg auf jedem einzelnen ihrer bilder die sie schießen werden dann irgendwelche satelliten spuren drauf haben die man mühselig rausrechnen muss.
Profi-gastronomen genauso die dann halt irgendwann wissen wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel auf meinem durch musterung bildern gucken werde kann ich's nicht vermeiden dass diese diese spuren überall sind da dann vielleicht auch meine helligkeits messungen stören zum beispiel.
Es gibt vor allen dingen halt auch noch wieder da den den kulturellen aspekt der ähnliches wie bei der lichtverschmutzung.
Es wird letztendlich so sein man wird ständig wenn man fertig ist.
Oder beziehungsweise halt einfach auch wenn wenn schon ein großteil dieser satelliten am himmel sind es werden ständig welche von diesen satelliten da sein wenn ich mich unter anderem an einem ort befinde wo die halt dann eben auch wirklich von der sonne beleuchtet sind.
Also das heißt also auf jeden fall in der dämmerung fasen im sommer heißt das die ganze nacht hier von deutschland aus dementsprechend halt eben diese satelliten zu sehen sein und.
Das wiederum übertragen jetzt auf das bild was was der laie vom sternenhimmel sieht.
Lichtpunkte welche lichtpunkte fallen mir eher ins auge das sind die die sich bewegen.
Das können vielleicht nur nur fünf oder nur zehn sein aber dadurch dass sie sich bewegen nimmt mein gehirn die viel viel deutlicher war als die anderen licht pünktchen die da auch noch sind die vielleicht sogar heller sind.
Aber die einfach nicht.
Ja heute auch mit mit flugzeugen schon so ist.
Ganz genau und dementsprechend also wenn wenn wirklich nur noch wenn wenn die zahl der satelliten sich sich so erhöht dass ich halt ständig ständig mindestens zwei drei vier davon am himmel habe,
konzentriert sich mein gehirn automatisch auf das künstliche blech geflügel was da oben rumschwirrt und nicht mehr auf die echten sterne und das ist schon auch irgendwie so ein so eine art,
paradigmenwechsel also wo sich wo sich einfach der anblick des sternhimmel komplett ändert da werden immer noch hunderte sterne dann am himmel zu sehen sein aber das menschliche gehirn fokussiert sich auf die drei vier satelliten die sich da bewegen,
und die die sterne treten in den hintergrund obwohl sie eigentlich in der überzahl sind.
Ich habe gehört dass die astros gemeinschaft im gespräch ist mit x ich frag mich nur ob da überhaupt irgendwas dran gemacht werden kann ich meine das bedeutet ja im prinzip entweder dann auf den verzicht auf den blick oder den verzicht auf einer weiteren nutzung des als.
Ja gut also das hat natürlich eine ganze reihe von von aspekten halt eben auch.
Es gibt ja jetzt schon man hat ja einen einen test satelliten beispielsweise hochgeschickt den man verdunkelt hat da gab's jetzt gerade gestern ist eine studie herausgekommen,
sagt dass der also nachdem er jetzt gerade eben vor kurzem seine seine endgültige umlaufbahn erreicht hat tatsächlich die helligkeit erreicht hat dass er mit bloßem auge nicht mehr zu sehen ist.
Das heißt aber natürlich trotzdem dass er auf den aufnahmen der gastronomen noch drauf sein wird also weil die ja lichtempfindlich sind als wie das wie das menschliche auge also da wird dann nach wie vor stören und das gilt auch dann für alle weiteren die man ähnlich gestalten würde.
Was heißt er verdunkeln also wie das problem sind doch die die die solarpanelen wenn ich das richtig.
Wenn man die solarpanels auf der einen seite aber hält natürlich auch die oberfläche des satelliten generell da kann man natürlich gucken was davon kann ich mit anstreichen oder sowas ähnliches also halt irgendwie.
Dieser farbe wo sich.
Möglichst nicht reflektierend ist das entscheidende also dunkel auf der einen seite aber halt wirklich nicht reflektierend ist das ist das wichtige dabei.
Vater black ist dieses super schwarz wurde.
Das wäre das wäre jetzt der extremfall sozusagen.
Das gemeine an der sache ist natürlich wenn ich den satelliten schwarz anmale heißt das heißt das tatsächlich dass der nichts mehr reflektiert.
Dieses reflektieren ist zum teil halt aber eben auch wichtig weil der würde sich dann ja durch sonnenlicht aufheizen und das will man eigentlich auch nicht also da muss auch irgendwie wieder abkühlen also man muss dann irgendwas irgendwas anderes halt als ausgleich haben also einfach anmalen geht auch nicht
das ist also alles gar nicht so einfach und dementsprechend wird sich für das problem,
selbst wenn die leute von von space-x sagen ja wir wollen da das bestmögliche erreichen für die gastronomie wird sich das nicht von heute auf morgen lösen lassen irgendwo.
Ja bei elon musk selber ist das ja immer so ein bisschen widersprüchlich der liefert dann natürlich über twitter gerne auch mal sprüche die also so ein bisschen.
Zeigen dass er das problem nicht so richtig verstanden hat.
Oder nicht verstehen will.
Oder nicht verstehen will das sagen wir es mal so das wage ich jetzt nicht zu beurteilen.
Gehe mal davon aus dass bei space-x selber eine ganze reihe von leuten sind die sich der tatsache bewusst sind dass das ein problem ist insbesondere weil man ja halt eben von seiten gerade der profi-gastronomen natürlich da auch an die ran getreten ist und auch versucht eine lösung für das problem zu finden.
Ja die die die frage der regelung ist natürlich eine ganz andere also.
Wie steht man da generell dazu dass dann eine firma einfach mal eben so mehrere zehntausend satelliten in die erdumlaufbahn schießen kann darf die das einfach so wer sich nämlich das wer gestartet das.
Welches gremium auf weltweiter ebene darf das erlauben oder auch nicht das ist eine politische frage.
Ist eine politische frage da ist glaube ich auch die die die die,
weltraum rechtliche öffentlichkeit auch etwas überrollt worden weil es einfach bisher sozusagen sich nicht so abgezeichnet hat und dann kommt halt so ein wahnsinniger sagt so wie wär's wenn wir einfach mal zehntausend nehmen so alle so wie was war das ja bisher sozusagen keine größenordnung war die man auch nur ansatzweise irgendeiner form als bezahlbar angesehen hat
nur dadurch dass er natürlich jetzt hier die economy sozusagen zur anwendung kommen und die dinger so günstig geworden sind durch diese massenproduktion,
ist es halt auf einmal möglichen jetzt haben wir das problem zu einer unzeit wo sozusagen die debatte darum noch gar nicht so richtig angefeuert wurde.
Schließen wir erstmal hier zu unserem thema ab hast du noch ein wunsch eine botschaft eine eine message die wir so bisher noch nicht rübergebracht haben die du noch unterbringen möchtest.
Also ich denke mal dass alles entscheidende ist und das haben wir jetzt halt auch gerade.
Im sinne der der vvs wieder ganz offen proklamiert bleiben sie neugierig weil ja letztendlich im moment durch corona virus so ziemlich alle veranstaltungen an stern warten,
bei astronomie verein abgesagt werden mussten einfach weil weil keine öffentliche veranstaltungen stattfinden können bleiben sie neugierig schauen sie an den sternenhimmel.
Das ist das was wir den leuten sagen im moment vielleicht nur virtuell oder mit eigenen augen aus dem eigenen garten um.
Oder.
Aber die spät hier ist amateur ist im allgemeinen sehr sehr sehr sehr willig um den sternhimmel eben auch zu zeigen also es gibt halt eben so viele leute die auch wirklich sich darauf spezialisiert haben,
insbesondere kindern jugendlichen aber halt eben auch interessierten leuten dass da oben zu zeigen zu erklären was es denn da gibt ohne dass die leute selber physik studiert haben.
Das trotzdem sehr sehr gut können auch eben die die dinge die man da oben sieht halt auch wirklich zu erklären und sich zeit zu nehmen halt eben auch für all die leute die da mehr wissen wollen.
Genau also planetarium sind immer ein guter anlaufpunkt dafür und wir hatten ja auch schon erwähnt es gibt eigentlich in allen.
Deutschlands und deutschsprachigen raum entsprechende stammtische vereinigungen gruppen et cetera zahlreicher art sodass wir sie hier jetzt alle gar nicht aufzählen wollen aber die vereinigung der sternenfreund ist da auf jeden fall schon mal ganz gut da,
anlaufpunkt um entsprechende orte herauszufinden nämlich an und einfach mal vorbeikommen und dann.
Bin mal wahrscheinlich auch schon sein eigenes teleskop haben mit toller nach führung und alles automatisch oder auch nicht.
Vielleicht einfach nur mal eben ganz gepflegt abends gerade im sommer auf die gartenliege legen und einfach nur nach oben.
Genau carolin vielen dank für das gespräch und ja an alle wie immer vielen dank fürs zuhören das.
Weiter.